This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 17th century novel Don Quixote, the hero, an aging knight, sets his sight on a woman named Aldonza Lorenzo. To everyone else, Aldonza is a rough-hewn peasant woman, ordinary in every way. But when Don Quixote looks at her, he sees someone special, a radiant, elegant woman, the embodiment of beauty and virtue. He speaks of her in exalted terms. He imagines her as the inspiration for his quests. He insists on her perfection, even if reality offers little support for his views. He even bestows on her a graceful name that speaks to the sweetness of her character, Delcinea.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在17世纪的小说《堂吉诃德》中，主人公是一位年迈的骑士，他看上了一位名叫阿尔东萨·洛伦佐的女子。在其他人眼里，阿尔东萨是一个粗糙的村妇，方方面面都普普通通。但当堂吉诃德看着她时，他看到的是一个特别的人，一位光芒四射、优雅的女性，她是美丽与美德的化身。他用崇高的词汇谈论她。他将她想象成他进行骑士探险的精神源泉。他坚信她是完美的，尽管现实几乎无法支撑他的看法。他甚至赐予她一个优雅的名字，以彰显她性格的甜美——达尔西内亚。
We may mark Don Quixote's romantic delusions, but it turns out he might have the last laugh. psychological research has begun to explore how our perceptions of other people can shape our relationships with them. That's true when it comes to wildly inflated estimates like Don Quixote's view of Dulcinea. But it's also true when it comes to views that are harshly critical. They too shape our relationships with our neighbors, our co-workers, and our partners. This week on Hidden Brain, how our minds shape what we see, how those perceptions create reality, and how to be a better partner. Imagine that the person you love most in the world is standing right in front of you.
我们或许会注意到堂吉诃德浪漫的妄想，但事实证明，笑到最后的可能正是他。心理学研究已经开始探讨我们对他人的感知如何塑造我们与他们的关系。当涉及到像堂吉诃德对杜尔西内亚那种极度夸大的看法时，情况确实如此。但这对于那些严厉批判的看法也同样适用。它们同样塑造了我们与邻居、同事以及伴侣的关系。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨：我们的心灵如何塑造我们的所见，这些感知如何创造现实，以及如何成为一个更好的伴侣。想象一下，世界上你最爱的那个人正站在你面前。
What do you see? Are you taking in their distinctive qualities, their particular characteristics, or are you seeing them through the lens of your own thoughts and feelings and anxieties? At the University of Maryland, psychologist Edward LeMay studies how people's fears and feelings skew their perceptions of their partners and how changing our perceptions can change the nature of our relationships. Ed Lameh, welcome to Hidden Brain.
你看到了什么？你是在接受他们独特的品质、特定的特征，还是透过你自己的思想、情感和焦虑的有色眼镜在看他们？在马里兰州立大学，心理学家爱德华·勒迈研究了人们的恐惧和情感如何扭曲他们对伴侣的感知，以及改变我们的感知如何改变我们关系的本质。埃德·勒迈，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks so much, Shankar. It's great to be here. And I want to go back some 750 years when a boy spotted a girl in Florence. The boy would go on to become one of the most celebrated writers and poets of all time. Who are these young people? And can you paint a picture for me of what happened that day? Sure. So the boy was Dante Allegory, and he met Beatrice Portionari at her father's house. Her father was hosting a Mayday party. And at this party, he essentially fell in love with Beatrice at love at first sight. He famously claimed at that moment that his vital spirit began to tremble, and he became a servant to love.
非常感谢，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。我想回到大约750年前，当时在佛罗伦萨，一个男孩偶遇了一个女孩。这个男孩后来成为了历史上最著名的作家和诗人之一。这些年轻人是谁？你能为我描绘一下那天发生的事情吗？当然。这个男孩是但丁·阿利吉耶里，他在贝亚特丽丝·波蒂纳里的父亲家里遇到了她。她的父亲当时正在举办五朔节派对。在这个派对上，他基本上对贝亚特丽丝一见钟情。他曾有一句名言：在那一刻，他的生命之灵开始颤抖，他成为了爱情的仆人。
Now, I understand that when they first met, they were both children. Yeah, that's correct. Dante was nine and Beatrice was just eight. Now, did they stay friends? Did their relationship blossom and grow from there? No, they did not. In fact, they didn't have many social interactions. Another notable interaction happened nine years later when Dante saw Beatrice walking down the street.
据我了解，他们初次见面时都还是孩子。是的，没错。但丁9岁，贝亚特丽丝只有8岁。那么，他们保持朋友关系了吗？他们的关系从那时起是否绽放并发展了呢？并没有。事实上，他们并没有太多的社交互动。另一次值得注意的互动发生在九年之后，当时但丁看到贝亚特丽丝走在街上。
She offered him a greeting. and Dante was so overwhelmed by that greeting that he returned to his room and reflected on that very minor social interaction, and it inspired his first sonnet. But aside from these two encounters, the party and this small interaction on the street, Dante and Beatrice actually had no contact. They may have seen each other in passing, but no formal courtship or even private conversations. both, in fact, actually married other people. Wow. Now, Dante held on to his image of Beatrice, especially after she died a few years later. Tell me what was happening in his mind and the image in his mind that he created of her. Yeah, so Beatrice passed away in 1290, and without that contact with Beatrice, his imagination was sort of let loose, unconstrained.
她向他致意，但丁被这个问候彻底震撼了，以至于他回到房间，反思了这次微不足道的社交互动，这激发了他的第一首十四首诗（十四行诗）。但除了这两次相遇——派对和街上的这次小型互动之外，但丁和贝亚特丽丝实际上没有任何接触。他们可能擦肩而见过彼此，但没有正式的求爱，甚至没有私下的对话。事实上，两人后来都各自嫁娶了别人。哇。但丁一直保留着他对贝亚特丽丝的印象，尤其是几年后她去世之后。告诉我，他脑海中究竟发生了什么，他在脑海中为她创造了怎样一个形象？是的，贝亚特丽丝于1290年去世，在没有与贝亚特丽丝接触的情况下，他的想象力可以说是被彻底释放了，不受任何约束。
And so he essentially constructed in his mind. an idealized version of Beatrice. In fact, his imagination of Beatrice eventually became the inspiration for his divine comedy, and Beatrice took on the role of Savior Network. I mean, it's kind of striking that a couple of chance encounters in this young man's life could end up playing such a substantial role in his later development as an artist. And, of course, someone looking at this from the outside would say, he hardly knew her. He was just making this all up in his head.
因此，他基本上在脑海中构建了一个理想化的贝亚特丽丝版本。事实上，他对贝亚特丽丝的想象最终成为了他的《神曲》的灵感来源，而贝亚特丽丝则扮演了拯救者的角色。我的意思是，这真是令人惊叹，这个年轻人生命中的几次偶然相遇，最终竟在他的晚期艺术发展中发挥了如此重要的作用。当然，旁观者会说，他根本不了解她。他只是在脑子里凭空捏造这一切。
Yeah, that's correct. But people do have a way of filling in the blanks and constructing images of people that are not strongly tied to reality. Much more recently, a similar storyline played out in a movie called 500 Days of Summer, which came out in 2009. Tell me the basic plot of the movie, Ed? Sure. In that movie, we have two main characters, Tom and Summer. And their relationship is characterized by a profound gap in perception. Tom falls in love with Summer, and he becomes convinced that they have a deep, meaningful partnership, whereas Summer insists from the very start that she's not looking for anything serious. And throughout their relationship, he continues to interpret their various interactions, the time they spend together, the signs of emotional close.
是的，没错。但人们确实有一种填补空白并构建与现实联系并不紧密的他人形象的方式。最近得多的一部电影《和莎莫的500天》中也上演了类似的故事线，该片于2009年上映。埃德，能告诉我这部电影的基本情节吗？当然。在那部电影中，我们有两个主要角色，汤姆和莎莫。他们的关系的特征是感知上存在着巨大的鸿沟。汤姆爱上了莎莫，他坚信他们有着深厚、有意义的伴侣关系，而莎莫从一开始就坚称她不想找任何认真的关系。在他们的整个关系中，他不断地解读他们之间的各种互动、他们在一起度过的时间、情感亲密的迹象。
the signs of intimacy, as evidence that the relationship is becoming something more than Summer even said she wanted at the beginning. And over time, Tom builds this narrative in his mind about how deep their relationship is and about the future that they're going to have together. It's a striking scene near the end of the movie when Tom and Samar have parted, but Tom continues to believe that the two of them are meant to be together. Describe what happens at the end of the movie, Ed? Yeah, there's this one central scene at the end of the movie. There's a voiceover at the start of the scene, and the voiceover says that Tom is walking to her apartment.
将亲密的迹象视为关系正在变得比莎莫在一开始所说想要的还要更进一步的证据。随着时间的推移，汤姆在脑海中构建了这样一个叙事：关于他们的关系有多深厚，以及他们将要共同拥有的未来。电影快结束时有一个令人印象深刻的场景，当时汤姆和莎莫已经分手，但汤姆仍然坚信他们俩是天生的一对。埃德，描述一下电影结尾发生了什么？是的，电影结尾有这样一个核心场景。场景开始时有一段画外音，画外音说汤姆正走向她的公寓。
I'm intoxicated by the promise of the evening. He believed that this time his expectations would align with reality. And they did this really creative thing where they had a split screen, and on one side of of this screen, you saw the label expectations. And on the other side of the screen, there was the label Reality. And on the expectation side of the screen, we see Tom imagining this warm, intimate reunion with Summer. Summer spots him from across the room. She lights up. She moves over toward him as if no time has passed between them. And in his mind, they slip easily back into the shared rhythm that they had before. There's lingering eye contact, private jokes,
我为这个夜晚的承诺而陶醉。他相信这一次他的期望会与现实相吻合。他们做了一件非常有创意的处理，就是采用了分屏，在这个屏幕的一侧，你看到了“期望”的标签。而在屏幕的另一侧，则是“现实”的标签。在屏幕的期望这一侧，我们看到汤姆想象着与莎莫进行一次温暖、亲密的重聚。莎莫从房间的那头认出了他。她眼睛一亮。她向他走过来，仿佛他们之间从未分开过时间。在他的脑海中，他们轻松地回到了以前共同的默契中。眼神流转，只有他们懂的笑话，
touches that signal that there's still a connection between them and still chemistry between them. And that chemistry is obvious to everybody else there at the party. The evening, as he imagines it, isn't just this pleasant encounter, but it's a turning point. It's this confirmation that what they had before isn't over. And that the distance between them, was just temporary and that this night will gently set things back into the course that they were on before. And what happens on the reality side of the screen? Well, on the reality side of the screen, we see something that's very different.
那些暗示他们之间仍然存在联系和化学反应的触碰。而这种化学反应对于派对上的其他人来说也是显而易见的。正如他所想象的那样，这个夜晚不仅仅是一次愉快的相遇，而是一个转折点。这是对他们过去的感情并未结束的确认。他们之间的距离只是暂时的，今晚将温和地让事情回到之前的轨道上。那么在屏幕的现实这一侧发生了什么呢？嗯，在屏幕的现实这一侧，我们看到了非常不同的情景。
So here, Summer greets Tom kindly, but briefly, with the same kind of politeness that she extends to all of the other guests at the party. Before moving on to circulate through the party, they have this very brief interaction. and their interactions are short and sort of surface level throughout the night. They lack the emotional charge that he was imagining. Tom spends much of the evening sort of on the margins, watching rather than participating and trying to see meaning in her gestures that don't quite hold. The room feels fuller, noisier, less centered on him than he expected.
在这里，莎莫亲切但简短地迎接了汤姆，带着她对待派对上所有其他客人的那种礼节。在穿梭于派对人群之前，他们进行了非常简短的互动。而且在整个晚上，他们的互动都很短，而且流于表面。它们缺乏他所想象的那种情感张力。汤姆在派对的边缘度过了大部分时间，与其说是参与，不如说是在观察，并试图在她那些不太贴切的 gestures（手势/举动）中寻找意义。房间感觉更拥挤、更嘈杂、远没有他预期的那样以他为中心。
And then quietly, but unmistakably, comes the moment where his imagination essentially collapses, is shattered. He notices that engagement ring that summer is wearing. She's become engaged to somebody else. And in that instant, the ambiguity disappears. I understand that as a young man, you yourself had an experience like Tom's. Can you paint me a picture of how it unfolded it? When I was in high school, I had a major crush on a friend of mine, but she was in a relationship with somebody else. And for a long time, I told myself that she probably liked me to, given our closeness, and that if she weren't already with someone, perhaps something might happen between us.
然后，悄然而又无可否认地，他的想象力基本上崩塌了、粉碎了。他注意到莎莫手上戴着的那枚订婚戒指。她已经和别人订婚了。在那一瞬间，模棱两可彻底消失了。我听说年轻时的你也有过类似汤姆的经历。你能为我描绘一下它是如何展开的吗？当我读高中时，我对我的一个女性朋友产生了好感，但她当时正和别人谈恋爱。很长一段时间里，我告诉自己，鉴于我们的亲密关系，她可能也喜欢我，如果她不是已经有了男朋友，也许我们之间可能会发生点什么。
So eventually, she and her boyfriend broke up, and I remember thinking, okay, this might be my chance. So not long after, she asked if I wanted to go to the mall, and I picked her up thinking that maybe this might actually be like a date or something. But when I got there, I was surprised to see that she invited her sister and another friend along, a guy that I didn't know. And her sister sat in the front seat, and she and the guy sat in the back. And as I was driving, the two of them in the back leaned over and started kissing in my back seat. Oh, dear. Oh, dear. I remember just sitting there kind of stunned. And that was the moment that it hit me that what I had been seeing all along,
所以最终，她和男友分手了，我记得当时想，好吧，这可能是我的机会。所以没过多久，她问我想不想去购物中心，我开车去接她，心想这实际上可能就像是一次约会什么的。但当我到那里时，我很惊讶地发现她邀请了她的姐姐和另一个朋友，一个我不认识的男生。她的姐姐坐在前排，她和那个男生坐在后排。当我开车时，坐在后座的那两个人靠过去，开始在我的后座接吻。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我记得自己就坐在那里，有点惊呆了。那一刻我突然意识到，我一直以来看到的那些迹象：
that she might be into me, really wasn't coming from her. It was coming from me. So at the psychological term projection has made its way into popular culture. We understand that it's not just movie projectors that create an image on the screen. Our minds do this, too? Yes, that's correct. By projection, what we mean is this tendency for people to use themselves as a guide to understanding other people. To be a little bit more concrete, it's a tendency for people to think that other people have the same thoughts, feelings, motivations, characteristics that they have. And it's been documented many, many times that people have this projection bias. We don't see our projections as projections, so what we think we see becomes what we actually see. It becomes our reality.
觉得她可能对我有意思，其实并不是来自她。而是来自我自己。那么，“投射”这个心理学词汇已经进入了大众文化。我们知道，不仅电影放映机能在银幕上创造图像，我们的心灵也会这样做吗？是的，没错。我们所说的投射，是指人们倾向于以自己为指南来理解其他人。具体一点来说，就是人们倾向于认为其他人拥有和他们自己相同的思想、动机、特征。并且已经被无数次证明，人们具有这种投射偏差。我们不认为我们的投射是投射，所以我们认为自己看到的，就成了我们实际看到的。它成了我们的现实。
When we come back, a look at the lenses that shape how we see our friends and partners and how they burnish or disfigure what is really in front of our eyes. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When we look at our friends and romantic partners, we feel that. as if we're seeing them clearly, taking in who they are, what they want. Other people may be gripped by delusions, we tell ourselves, but we see things clearly. Psychologist Edward LeMay has found that these projections can both help and harm our relationships.
稍后回来，我们将审视塑造我们如何看待朋友和伴侣的有色眼镜，以及它们如何美化或扭曲了我们眼前真实存在的东西。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当我们审视我们的朋友和浪漫伴侣时，我们感觉。就好像我们在清晰地看到他们，在接纳他们是谁、他们想要什么。我们告诉自己，其他人可能会被妄想所困扰，但我们看得很清楚。心理学家爱德华·勒迈发现，这些投射既可以帮助我们，也可以伤害我们的关系。
Ed, you've studied the scenario described in 500 days of summer where one person has romantic feelings for a friend and assumes the friend feels the same way. Describe the setup of your study and what you found? I've conducted a few studies on platonic friendships between men and women. And it's important to note that these are heterosexual men and women. And in one study, we just took a snapshot of what's happening in the relationship. But then in the other study, we actually followed people over time to look at how these friendships progress.
埃德，你研究过《和莎莫的500天》中描述的情景，其中一个人对朋友产生了好感，并假设对方也有同感。请描述一下你的研究设置以及你的发现？我针对男性和女性之间的柏拉图式友谊做了一些研究。需要指出的是，这些都是异性恋男女。在其中一项研究中，我们只是对关系中正在发生的事情进行了截屏式的考察；但在另一项研究中，我们实际上对人们进行了长时间的追踪，以观察这些友谊是如何进展的。
One of the central findings across both studies was that when people had romantic desires for their friend, they projected this desire onto their friend. They believed that their friend reciprocated their romantic feelings. Now, importantly, we also had the friend in the study. So we could measure whether the friend actually reciprocated. And what we found was that when people had romantic attraction toward their friend, they greatly exaggerated the extent to which their friend reciprocated their romantic attraction. In other words, they projected their romantic attraction. Now, I'm wondering, did this projection have an effect on the relationship between these two people? So if I am overestimating how much someone is attracted to me, does that eventually change how they actually feel toward me?
这两项研究的核心发现之一是，当人们对朋友产生浪漫的渴望时，他们会将这种渴望投射到朋友身上。他们相信朋友对他们的浪漫情感作出了回应。重要的是，我们的研究中也有这位朋友参与。因此我们可以衡量这位朋友是否真的作出了回应。我们发现的是，当人们对朋友产生浪漫吸引时，他们极大地夸大了朋友对他们的浪漫吸引作出回应的程度。换句话说，他们投射了自己的浪漫吸引。现在我很好奇，这种投射会对这两个人之间的关系产生影响吗？如果我高估了某人对我有多大吸引力，这最终会改变他们对我的实际感觉吗？
Yes, it does. Projection often has consequences because it shapes our behavior. And so in this particular case, the illusion that the friend reciprocated desire seemed to give people courage to pursue their friend. So they engaged in a variety of behaviors that social scientists refer to as relationship initiation behaviors. These include things like directly expressing one's interest in the other person, but more bold things like moving in for a kiss, looking deep into a person's eyes, engaging in flirting, and then trying to enhance one's appearance, doing whatever one can to attract the other person. And people who engaged in these behaviors, there was sort of a self-fulfilling prophecy that on. unfolded. So the friend ended up becoming more interested in them over time because we all like to receive attention. We all like to be valued. And so people whose projection gave them the courage to initiate the romantic relationship ended up in many cases getting what they actually wanted, which is a friend who did indeed like them back. So initially it seemed to be a bias and an error in judgment, but that that expectation or belief that the friend reciprocated actually
是的，确实会。投射通常会产生后果，因为它会塑造我们的行为。所以在这种特殊情况下，朋友作出了回应这种错觉，似乎给了人们追求朋友的勇气。因此，他们参与了社会科学家所称的“关系发起行为”的各种行为。这些行为包括直接表达自己对另一个人的兴趣，但也包括更大胆的行为，比如凑过去亲吻、深情凝视一个人的眼睛、调情，然后试图提升自己的外表，尽一切可能吸引另一个人。那些从事这些行为的人，展开了一个自我实现的预言。因此，随着时间的推移，朋友最终对他们变得更感兴趣，因为我们都喜欢接受关注。我们都喜欢被重视。因此，那些投射给了他们勇气去发起这段浪漫关系的人，在许多情况下最终得到了他们真正想要的东西，也就是一个确实也喜欢他们的朋友。所以最初这似乎是一种偏见和判断错误，但这种朋友作出了回应的期望或信念，实际上
ended up becoming true over time. So it might not have been the case with Tom and Summer in the movie, and it might not have been the case with you and your friend in high school, but in general, what you're finding is that these projections have powerful effects, not just on our behavior, but then on the subsequent behavior of the person that we're interested in. Yeah, that's correct. the projections can end up having an influence on other people's behavior and how other people feel about you. But your point is also a good one that it doesn't always happen that way. There needs to be
随着时间的推移，最终变成了现实。所以这可能不适用于电影中的汤姆和莎莫，也可能不适用于你和你在高中的朋友，但总的来说，你的发现是，这些投射不仅对我们的行为产生强大影响，而且对我们感兴趣的人随后的行为也产生强大影响。是的，没错。这些投射最终可能会对其他人的行为以及其他人对你的感觉产生影响。但你的观点也很好，即这种情况并不总是以这种方式发生。在开始时，需要
at the outset a belief that this person who's engaging in the projection is a compatible partner for you. Do you see them as somebody who is desirable, who fits what you're looking for in a romantic partner. And if that's not true, then no matter how much the person projects, the relationship isn't going to develop. So there needs to be a bit of compatibility, you could say, from the start. So that's research into how a romantic relationship might get started. But you found that our projections don't stop there. Once a relationship gets underway, we continue to project our own feelings and motives onto our partners with both positive and negative consequences for our bond. Let's look at those one by one. What are the positive effects of projecting
有一种信念，即这个正在进行投射的人是你一个兼容的伴侣。你是否认为他们是一个具有吸引力的人，符合你在浪漫伴侣中寻找的标准？如果这不是真的，那么无论这个人如何投射，这段关系都不会发展。所以你可以说，从一开始就需要有一点兼容性。这就是关于浪漫关系如何开始的研究。但你发现我们的投射并未止步于此。一旦关系开始，我们就会继续将自己的感受和动机投射到我们的伴侣身上，这对我们的关系既有积极的后果，也有消极的后果。让我们逐一来看。埃德，将关怀和支持的情感投射到伴侣身上有哪些积极的影响？
caring and supportive feelings onto a partner, Ed? Yes, there's plenty of evidence that this projection process even happens within ongoing relationships with partners that you know very well. And several of my studies have focused on care. And that's because care is central to close relationships. When we're in a close relationship, we've very much want the other person to care for our needs. And so whether or not we see the other person as caring should have a lot of implications for how that relationship feels, how satisfying it is, and how it develops over time. And so in some of our early studies, we looked at married couples and their projection of care onto their spouse. And what we found was that when one person
是的，有大量的证据表明，这种投射过程甚至发生在与非常熟悉的伴侣的持续关系中。我的几项研究都集中在“关怀”上。这是因为关怀是亲密关系的核心。当我们处于亲密关系中时，我们非常希望对方能够关心我们的需求。因此，我们是否认为对方是关怀的，会对这段关系的感觉、满意度以及随后的发展产生很多影响。因此，在我们早期的某些研究中，我们观察了已婚夫妇及其对配偶的关怀投射。我们发现，当一个人
cared deeply about their partner's welfare and they were motivated to provide support to their partner, they believed that their partner felt the same way toward them in return. And once again, like the friendship study, we actually had the partner participate in the study too. So we had their reports of how motivated they were to provide support to the person doing the perceiving and how much they actually cared for them. And again, what we found was this exaggeration. So those who strongly cared for their spouse exaggerated the extent to which their spouse cared for them.
深深关怀伴侣的福祉并且有动机为伴侣提供支持时，他们相信他们的伴侣也会以同样的方式回报他们。再次像友谊研究一样，我们实际上也让伴侣参与了研究。因此我们有了他们关于自己有多大动机为进行感知的人提供支持以及他们实际上有多么关怀对方的报告。我们再次发现的是这种夸大。因此，那些极度关怀配偶的人夸大了配偶关怀他们的程度。
And likewise, it works in the negative direction, too, though. Those who have low care for their partner also believe that their partners have low care for them. I want to play you a clip from the TV show Madman that features Betty, played by January Jones. and in this scene she tells her husband Don, played by John Hamm, that she knows he's been having an affair. Jimmy told me everything.
同样，它也会以消极的方向起作用。那些对伴侣关怀度低的人也相信他们的伴侣对他们的关怀度低。我想给你放一段电视剧《广告狂人》的片段，其中由珍纽瑞·琼斯饰演贝蒂。在这个场景中，她告诉由乔恩·哈姆饰演的丈夫唐，她知道他一直在外遇。吉米把一切都告诉我了。
Jimmy, he hates me. He told me everything. Oh, please. What the hell did he say? So you can pick it apart? Twist all my words. I'm not going to dignify Jimmy Barrett with a response. He's a big mouth. And don't pretend I don't know how he looks at you.
吉米？他恨我。他把一切都告诉我了。噢，拜托。他到底说了什么？这样你就可以挑刺了？扭曲我说的所有话？我不会降低身份去回应吉米·巴雷特。他是个大嘴巴。别假装我不知道他是怎么看你的。
So I feel like the script writers were being psychologically astute here, Ed. what's happening in this scene? This is a great example of projection, this time projecting something that's negative. So in this scene, Don is having an affair. And when he insinuates that something might be going on between Betty and Jimmy, it suggests that he is seeing his own infidelity and his inclinations for infidelity in his partner. He's projecting his own interest in other people onto her. I understand that you once heard of a real-life story along these lines. A student shared an account of a couple who had a similar dynamic to that scene from Mad Men.
所以我觉得编剧在这里非常具有心理学敏锐度，埃德，这个场景中发生了什么？这是一个很好的投射例子，这一次投射的是消极的东西。在这个场景中，唐正在外遇。当他暗示贝蒂和吉米之间可能发生了什么时，这表明他在伴侣身上看到了自己的不忠以及自己对不忠的倾向。他将自己对其他人的兴趣投射到了她身上。我听说你曾经听过一个现实生活中与此类似的真实故事。一个学生分享了一对情侣的故事，他们有着类似于《广告狂人》那个场景的动态。
Yeah, a student once told me about a couple that she was friends with. The guy was openly flirtatious with other women, even while he was in a relationship. And at the same time, he was often suspicious of his partner. He was accusing her of being interested in other people, even though she insisted that she wasn't. What stood out was that the very thing that he was doing, being drawn to other people outside of the relationship, seemed to shape how he saw her. Now, one thing that can make this complicated ed is that it can be difficult to tell
是的，一个学生曾向我讲述了一对她很熟悉的情侣。那个男生对其他女性公开调情，甚至在他有伴侣的时候也是如此。与此同时，他经常对他的伴侣起疑心。他指责她对其他人感兴趣，尽管她坚称自己没有。引人注目的是，他自己正在做的事情——被关系之外的其他人所吸引——似乎塑造了他如何看待她。埃德，使这变得复杂的一点是，要分辨我们何时是准确地看清现实，何时是将我们自己内心的不安全感或内心的态度投射到世界上，可能会很困难。假设有一个人担心，比如说，她的丈夫对她不忠。这是否自动意味着她自己也有一颗不安分的心呢？我的意思是，难道她不可能是在准确地看清现实吗？
when we are seeing reality accurately and when we are projecting our own inner insecurities or our own inner attitudes onto the world. So let's say you have a person who is concerned that, let's say, her husband is cheating on her. Does that automatically mean that she herself has a wandering eye? I mean, isn't it possible that she's seeing reality accurately? This is a great point, Shankar, and it's an important qualification to research on bias in relationships generally. And that is that our perceptions are really a mix of both accuracy and bias. We are, to some degree, picking up on our partners actually.
这是一个极好的观点，尚卡尔，这也是对关于关系中偏见的研究的一个重要限定。那就是，我们的 perceptions（感知）实际上是准确性和偏见两者的混合。我们在某种程度上确实捕捉到了伴侣对我们的真实想法、感受和动机。但我们的感知同时也受到我们带入这段关系的各种有色眼镜、即我们自己脑海中正在发生的事情的塑造。这项研究中也是如此。事实上，在我们迄今为止讨论的所有研究中，都有投射的证据，但也有读心方面存在一定准确性的证据。人们在理解伴侣在多大程度上关怀他们方面在一定程度上是准确的，
thoughts and feelings toward us and motivations. But our perceptions are also shaped by the various lenses that we bring to the relationship, what's going on in our own minds. And that's the case in this research as well. In fact, in all of the research we've talked about up until now, there's evidence for projection, but there's also evidence for a bit of accuracy in mind reading. People are accurate to some degree in understanding. how much their partners care for them
以及他们的朋友对他们有多大的浪漫兴趣，以及他们的伴侣对替代伴侣和其他人在多大程度上感兴趣。所以，是的，这是准确性和偏见的结合。我想花一点时间探讨一下为什么我们会进行这么多的投射，埃德。你和其他人认为，当我们试图理解别人时，我们使用的大部分材料都来自我们自己的大脑。因此我可能对你了解一些，
and how much their friends are romantically interested in them and how much their partners are interested in alternative partners and other people. So, yes, it's a blend of accuracy and bias. I want to spend a moment on why it is that we do so much projection, Ed. You and others argue that as we try to see someone else, most of the material we're working with comes from our own mind. So I might know a few things about you,
但我可以对你有很多想法。当我权衡所有事情时，我自己的想法最终比实际证据更有分量。是的，没错。我们没有看到更强的准确性效应有很多原因。我可以简要介绍其中几个。其一是许多行为是模棱两可的。我们不知道是什么驱使我们的伴侣以特定方式行事。这为为主观解释留下了空间。
but I can think a lot of thoughts about you. And when I weigh everything, my own thoughts end up counting for more than the actual evidence. Yes, that's correct. There are plenty of reasons why we don't see stronger accuracy effects. And I can briefly go over a few of those. So one is that many behaviors are ambiguous. We don't know what's driving our partner to behave in a particular way. And that creates room for subjective interpretations.
因此，例如，当我们的伴侣给我们不想要的建议时，当我们正在倾诉我们在工作中遇到的问题时（你知道，我们只是想把情绪宣泄出来，或许希望能获得一点情感支持），我们的伙伴却告诉我们应该如何处理它，这可能会（你知道的）有点扫兴。你可以用以下两种方式之一来解读这一点：可能是我的伙伴试图帮我解决问题，因为他们关心我；也可能是我的伙伴根本没有认真听我想要和需要的是什么。或者也许作为另一个例子，当你心烦意乱时，伴侣可能会给你空间。你可以用几种不同的方式来解读这一点。也许是我的伙伴在尊重我的需求。
So, for example, when our partner gives us unwanted advice, when we're venting about a problem we're having at work, you know, we just want to get our feelings out and maybe receive a bit of emotional support. And our partner tells us how we should handle it, which can be, you know, a bit off-putting. You could interpret that in one of two ways. It could be that my partner is trying to help me solve a problem because they care for me or that my partner is not really listening to what I want to need. Or perhaps, as another example, a partner might give you space when you're upset. And you could interpret that in a couple different ways. Maybe it's that my partner is respecting my needs.
或者也许是因为我的伙伴不关心。我的伙伴不想谈论是什么在困扰我。因此，在我们进行的许多互动中，都有主观解释的空间。最后，重要的是要记住，在任何持续的关系中，都有这么多的行为正在上演。其中一些是支持性的，而另一些则不是。这就留下了注意力和记忆偏见的余地。你决定关注什么？你记得的是积极的行为还是消极的？
Or perhaps it's that my partner doesn't care. My partner doesn't want to talk about what's bothering me. So there's room for subjective interpretation in many of the interactions that we have. And then finally, it's important to keep in mind that within any ongoing relationship, there are so many behaviors that are being enacted. And some of them are supportive and some of them are not. And that leaves room for biases and attention and memory. What do you decide to attend to? What do you remember the positive behaviors or the negative?
我认为这也可以解释我们在关系中看到的人们对彼此感知的某些不匹配。你提出了一个迷人的观点：不仅我们对另一个人的感知会影响我们看待他们的方式，而且我们对另一个人的行为也会影响我们看待他们的方式。这在你的一个朋友身上得到了体现，他在职场上与一位以有点脾气暴躁而闻名的同事维持着一种关系。埃德，你能告诉我那个故事吗？好的，没问题。我有一个朋友，他曾与一位名叫丹的高级同事共事。而丹
I think that too can explain some of the mismatch we see in people's perceptions of each other within relationships. You make the fascinating point that it's not just our perceptions toward another person that affects the way we see them, but that our behavior toward another person can affect the way we see them. This played out for a friend of yours in a relationship he had in the workplace with a colleague who was known to be a bit of a grump. Can you tell me that story, Ed? Yeah, sure. So I have a friend who worked with a senior colleague named Dan. And Dan had a
以脾气暴躁、令人畏惧但又才华横溢而闻名。我认为这也是他令人畏惧的部分原因。办公室里的大多数人都与他保持距离。有一次，我的朋友必须做一个非常重要的演讲，需要与他协调。我的朋友非常紧张，以至于他敢于向丹本人提及他的忧虑。让我的朋友惊讶的是，当他提到自己的焦虑时，丹是多么的友善和支持。他不遗余力地帮助我的朋友准备并缓解他的紧张情绪。在那之后，我的朋友开始以不同的方式接近丹。他没有避开他，而是向丹寻求帮助并让他更多地参与进来，因为他
reputation for being grumpy and intimidating, but also brilliant. I think that was part of why he was intimidating to people. And most people in the office kept their distance from him. At one point, my friend had to give a very important presentation and needed to quote, coordinate with him. My friend was so nervous that he ventured to mention his apprehension to Dan himself. And what surprised my friend was how kind and supportive Dan was when he mentioned his anxiety. He went out of his way to help my friend prepare and to manage his nerves. And after that, my friend started approaching Dan differently. Instead of avoiding him, he would ask Dan for help and involve him more because he
知道这会激发丹更愉快的一面。随着时间的推移，这彻底改变了我朋友对丹的体验。他不再觉得丹令人畏惧。他觉得丹更有支持性和平易近人。办公室里的其他人似乎没有那种相同的体验，也许是因为他们不知道解锁丹这一面的所谓秘诀。因此，他们开玩笑地开始称我的朋友为“丹语者”。好吧，你可以看到这在多种情境下是多么容易发生。你知道，某人可能有点害羞。所以你可能会说，好吧这个人很害羞。
knew that that would sort of bring out this more pleasant side of Dan. And over time, that completely changed how my friend experienced Dan. He no longer saw Dan as intimidating. He saw him as much more supportive and approachable. Other people in the office didn't seem to have that same experience, maybe because they didn't know the sort of secret to unlocking this part of Dan. And so they jokingly started calling my friend the Dan whisperer. Well, you can see how this can happen so easily in multiple contexts. You know, someone might be a little shy. And so you might say, okay, this person is shy.
让我不要因为邀请他们参加某些办公室聚会而去打扰他们，因为我知道他们很害羞。他们不会喜欢的。所以我们解读这些微小的信号，然后从这些微小的信号中得出很多结论，然后我们的行为最终会加剧我们一开始可能看到的信号。是的，没错。我们的行为可以通过改变另一个人实际对我们的反应来加剧这些信号。但除此之外，我们的行为还可以改变我们自己对这次互动将会怎样的期望。它可以激发出某人的另一面，并促使我们认为这段关系将会不同。既然我已经以这种特定方式行事了。
Let me not bother by, you know, inviting them to some office gathering because I know they're shy. They're not going to like it. And so we read these little signals and then we draw a lot from those little signals. and then our behavior then ends up exacerbating the signals that we may have seen in the first place. Yeah, that's correct. Our behavior can exacerbate those signals by changing how the other person actually responds to us. But in addition, our behavior can alter our own expectations regarding what this interaction is going to be like. It can sort of bring out another side of somebody and cause us to think that the relationship is going to be different. now that I behaved in this particular way.
因此，将这一见解带回到我们的浪漫关系中，我们对伴侣的行为如何塑造我们最终看待他们的方式？所以在持续的关系中，我们不仅看伴侣以弄清楚伴侣对我们的感觉，我们还会审视我们自己。我们自己的行为，例如我们对伴侣是否热情和支持，或者相反，我们对伴侣是否冷漠和疏离，可以塑造我们认为伴侣如何看待我们，他们是否将我们视为热情的伴侣或冷漠的伴侣。我们大多数人都有这样的期望：热情会引发其他人积极的感情，
So bringing this insight back to our romantic relationships, how does our behavior toward our partners shape the way we end up seeing them? So in ongoing relationships, we don't just look at our partner to figure out how our partner feels about us, but we also look at ourselves. Our own behavior, such as whether we're warm and supportive toward our partner, or conversely, whether we're cold and distant toward our partner, can shape how we think our partners see us, whether they see us as a warm partner or a cold partner. And most of us have expectations that warmth elicits positive feelings in other people,
引发其他人积极的态度。而冷漠会引发其他人消极的感情和态度。因此，仅通过保持热情，我们就为自己提供了一个理由，让我们确信其他人重视我们、喜欢我们、想要和我们在一起。所以当我们热情时，它有助于我们感到更加安全，确信自己被爱。而当我们冷漠时，它可能会给我们一个理由，转而对其他人有多喜欢我们或想要和我们在一起产生怀疑。在我关于这个主题的研究中，我们发现，在日常生活中，人们在对伴侣特别热情的日子里，会对自己被伴侣重视感到更有信心；
positive attitudes in other people. And that coldness elicits negative feelings and attitudes in other people. So just by being warm, we sort of provide ourselves with a reason to be confident that other people value us and like us and want to be with us. So when we are warm, it helps us feel more secure that we're loved. And when we're cold, it can give us a reason to instead have doubts about how much others like us or want to be around us. In the studies I've done on this topic, we find that in daily life, people feel more confident that they're valued by their partners on days when they're especially warm toward their partners. and they feel less confident, more insecure about how much their partners value them on days when they're cold.
而在冷漠的日子里，他们会感到不那么自信，对伴侣有多重视他们感到更加没有安全感。我们还做了实验，操纵一个人对伴侣的行为。因此我们鼓励他们以支持或不支持的方式行事。我们发现这种实验操纵改变了该人的期望以及被伴侣重视的感觉。因此，行为是理解一个人如何感到被爱或不被爱的重要拼图。埃德，我了解到恋爱中的人们通常通过他们希望关系能够顺利进行的愿望这副有色眼镜来看到他们的伴侣。你能解释一下这种动态是如何运作的吗？
We've also done experiments where we've manipulated a person's behavior toward their partner. So we're encouraging them to behave in a supportive or unsupportive way. And we find that this experimental manipulation alters the person's expectations and feelings of being valued by their partner. So behavior is an important piece of the puzzle. when it comes to understanding how a person comes to feel loved or unloved. Ed, I understand that people in relationships commonly see their partners through the lens of how much they want the relationship to work. Can you explain this dynamic how it works?
这是我们认为是“一厢情愿”或更专业一点的“动机性认知”的一个例子。这种观点认为，我们的思考方式被我们的愿望所偏见。我们以一种在主观上证实我们最希望世界成为什么样子的方式来看待世界。在关系中也是如此。作为这方面的一个具体例子，当我们强烈渴望这段关系时，如果伴侣的表现方式暗示缺乏关怀，我们会做的是，
This is an example of what we like to think of as wishful thinking or to be a little bit more technical, motivated cognition. This idea that the way we think, is biased by what we want. And we see the world in a way that sort of subjectively confirms what we most want the world to be like. And that also is the case within relationships. As one concrete example of this, when we strongly want the relationship, if the partner behaves in a way that suggests lack of care, what we do,
我们会编造借口，让我们尽管面对眼前不关怀的行为，依然能够感到被关怀。因此我在我的工作中发现的一种借口是，人们会说服自己，他们没有足够清楚地将自己的需求传达给伴侣。这就解释了为什么他们的伴侣会表现出这种不支持的行为。并不是伴侣不关心我，而是伴侣根本不知道我在这特定情况下想要什么、需要什么。因此，这种动机性认知的戏剧性例子来自电视剧《绝命毒师》。
we sort of invent excuses that allow us to still feel cared for despite the uncaring behavior that's right in front of us. So one kind of excuse that I found in my work is that people will convince themselves that they didn't clearly enough communicate their needs to their partner. And that explains why their partner is behaving in this unsupportive way. It's not that the partner doesn't care for me, but rather it's the partner just didn't know what I wanted. needed in this particular situation. So a dramatic example of this kind of motivated cognition comes from the television show Breaking
在剧中，由布莱恩·科兰斯顿饰演的沃尔特·怀特是一名高中化学老师，为了支付癌症治疗费用，他转向了制造和销售毒品。在这个场景中，他的妻子斯凯勒（由安娜·冈饰演）
Bad. In the show, Walter White, who is played by Brian Cranston, is a high school chemistry teacher who is turned to making and selling drugs in an effort to pay for his cancer treatment. In this scene, his wife, Skyler, played by Anna Gunn,
在发现真相后，试图说服他应该去报警。你不是什么顽固的罪犯，沃尔特，你已经泥足深陷了。这就是我们告诉他们的。这就是真相。这不是真相。当然是的。
tries to convince him once she has found out what's going on, that they should go to the police. You are not Some hardened criminal, Walt, you are in over your head. That's what we tell them. That's the truth. It's not the truth. Of course it is.
学校老师，癌症，急需用钱。好了，我们说完了。被诱导去工作，甚至无法退出。你自己告诉我的，沃尔特。埃德，你对斯凯勒在这个场景中的想法和说法有什么看法？嗯，我认为这个场景中引人注目的是，斯凯勒正试图讲述一个关于沃尔特是谁的故事，这使她能够理解这种情况并留在关系中。她将他塑造成一个泥足深陷的人，一个基本上被卷入
School teacher, cancer, desperate for money. Okay, we're done. Roped into working for, unable to even quit. You told me that yourself, Walt. Ed, what's your sense of what Skyler is thinking and saying in this scene? Well, I think that what's striking in this scene is that Skyler is trying to tell a story about who Walter is that allows her to make sense of the situation and to stay in the relationship. She frames him as someone who's in over his head, who's basically a good person who got pulled into
坏事的好人。这是一个非常令人同情的他的版本。但在故事的那个阶段，那已经不是沃尔特了。我认为你在这里看到的是斯凯勒有动机的感知。她不仅仅是在描述他。她是在以一种保护她深切关怀的东西（即她的婚姻和她的家庭）的方式来解读他。因此，从某种意义上说，她是在坚持他较早的版本或更充满希望的版本，因为那是使她能够与他保持联系的版本。我想给你放一段1997年电影《心灵捕手》的片段。在这个场景中，由明妮·德赖弗饰演的斯凯勒正处于一段新的恋情中。
something bad. And that's a very sympathetic version of him. But at that point in the story, that's really not who Walt is anymore. And I think what you're seeing here is Skyler's motivated perception. She's not just describing him. She's interpreting him in a way that protects something that she deeply cares about, which is her marriage and her family. So she's in a sense holding on to an earlier version of him or a more hopeful version of him because that's the version that makes it possible for her to stay connected with him. I want to play you a clip from the 1997 movie Goodwill Hunting. In this scene, Skyler, played by Mini Driver, is in a new relationship. with Will, who's played by Matt Damon,
与由马特·达蒙饰演的威尔在一起，斯凯勒正要搬去加州，并刚刚邀请威尔和她一起去。威尔问她怎么知道她真的想要他的陪伴。我知道，因为我能感觉到。因为你说的这是一件非常严肃的事情。我的意思是，你下周可能会在加州，
and Skyler is moving to California and has just asked Will to come with her. Will asks how she knows that she really wants his company. I know because I feel it. Because that's a really serious thing you're saying. I mean, you could be in California next week
你知道的，你可能会发现关于我一些你不喜欢的事情，你知道的，也许你希望你没有说过那样的话，但是你知道的，这是一件如此严肃的事情。以至于你无法收回它，现在我被困在了加州。如果有人并不是真的想和我在一起，只会希望他们能收回这话。什么？什么收回？
and you know, you might find out something about me you don't like and, you know, maybe you wish you hadn't said that, but you know, it's such a serious thing. that you can't take it back and now I'm stuck in California. Someone doesn't really want to be with me just wish they had a take back. What? What's the take back?
你知道的，你可能会发现我身上有些你并不喜欢的地方，而且，你知道的，也许你会希望自己没说过那样的话，但你知道，这是一件很严重的事情，你无法收回它，现在我被困在加利福尼亚了。有人其实并不想和我在一起，只是希望他们能收回那些话。什么？什么叫收回？
I don't want a take back. I just want you to come to California with me. So Ed, what do you hear Will expressing there? How does it relate to your research on the influence of one partner's insecurity within a relationship? What I hear in that clip is someone who's deeply unsure about his value as a relationship. relationship partner. And in particular, unsure about whether Schuyler sees anything worthwhile in having him as a relationship partner. And because of that, he's not just reacting to what Schuyler is doing. He's interpreting the relationship through the lens of his insecurities.
48|||我不要收回。我只是想让你和我一起去加州。Ed，你觉得Will在那里表达了什么？这与你关于伴侣在关系中不安全感影响的研究有什么关系？我在那个片段中听到的是，他对自己在恋爱关系中的价值深感不确定。尤其是，他对舒勒是否认为他是合适的恋爱伴侣有任何价值感到不确定。正因为如此，他不仅仅是在对舒勒的所作所为做出反应。他是在通过自己不安全感的镜头来诠释这段关系。
And he's not just saying, you know, look, I'm really insecure and I'm worried that this is going to fall apart. He's basically saying, what happens when we get to California and you decide you don't want to be with me? So in other words, he's seeing in her behavior, her future behavior, his present insecurities. Yes, that's correct. He is using his insecurities regarding how much she values him to forecast where this relationship will go. And he has a very pessimistic outlook on the future of their relationship. He's expecting rejection, essentially. I mean, it's amazing how many of these projections end up being effectively self-fulfilling prophecies. That's correct, yeah, because having these perceptions of being devalued by the partner
而且他不仅仅是说，你知道，看吧，我真的很没有安全感，我担心这段关系会分崩离析。他基本上是在说，当我们到了加州，你决定不想和我在一起了，会发生什么？换句话说，他在她的行为中——她未来的行为中——看到了他自己目前的不安全感。是的，没错。他正在用自己关于她有多大程度上珍视他的不安全感，来预测这段关系将走向何方。他对他们关系的未来有着非常悲观的看法。从本质上讲，他期待着被拒绝。我的意思是，令人惊奇的是，这些预测中有多少最终都变成了自我实现的预言。没错，是的，因为有了被伴侣贬低的感知，
and questioning the authenticity of the partner's expressions of love can lead the insecure person into behaving in negative ways that can actually push the partner away. When we ask ourselves, what our partners are thinking in feeling, it can feel like we're simply reading reality. But as Ed's research shows, we're often reading our own fears, hopes, and expectations. These projections can quietly shape the course of a relationship for better and for worse. When we come back, how to work skillfully with the projections we cast onto those we love. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. As you've listened to the story, have you
并且质疑伴侣表达爱意的真实性，这可能会导致缺乏安全感的人做出消极的行为，从而实际上把伴侣推开。当我们自问伴侣心里在想什么、感受什么时，这感觉就像我们只是在解读现实。但正如Ed的研究表明的那样，我们往往是在解读我们自己的恐惧、希望和期望。这些预测可以静悄悄地塑造一段关系走向更好或更坏的轨迹。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何巧妙地应对我们投射到所爱之人身上的种种预测。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。在听这个故事的时候，你有没有
Thought of ways in which your own projections shape your behavior and feelings toward your partner? Can you think of times when other people's projections have shaped the way they behave toward you? If you have a personal story you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org using the subject line, projections. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Psychologist Ed LeMay's research suggests that we persistently view our partners through lenses colored by our own fears, desires,
想过，你自己的预测是如何塑造你对伴侣的行为和感受的？你能想起其他人如何通过他们的预测来塑造他们对待你的方式吗？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者对本期节目的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将文件发送至Feedback@hiddenbrain.org，邮件主题请写：projections（预测）。再重复一遍，邮箱是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。心理学家Ed LeMay的研究表明，我们总是透过被我们自身的恐惧、欲望，
and insecurities. These filters cause us to misread our partners in ways that can create confusion, conflict, and distance. Ed suggests that by becoming aware of these projections and working with them in intentional, skillful ways, we can improve our relationships with the people we love. Ed, I'm wondering whether we want to see our partners as clearly as possible, or we want to see them as skillfully as possible. What do you think? Well, I think that the key is that we don't want to see our partners unrealistically. We want to see them generously while still staying grounded in reality. And I think that one way people do this is by giving their partner the benefit of the doubt.
以及不安全感所着色的滤镜来看待我们的伴侣。这些滤镜导致我们误解伴侣，从而制造出困惑、冲突和疏离。Ed建议，通过意识到这些预测，并以有意、巧妙的方式来处理它们，我们可以改善与所爱之人的关系。Ed，我想知道，我们是希望尽可能清晰地看到我们的伴侣，还是希望尽可能巧妙地看到他们？你怎么看？嗯，我认为关键在于，我们不想不切实际地看待伴侣。我们希望在脚踏实地面对现实的同时，慷慨地看待他们。我认为人们做到这一点的一个方法就是选择相信伴侣。
when things are ambiguous, assuming good intentions rather than the worst. But at the same time, it's important to stay open to new information. So if there's a consistent pattern of troubling behavior, you don't want to explain that a way. In fact, that's why people, some people, end up staying in relationships that are really not good for them. So it's really about a balance. holding on to a generally positive view of the partner while still updating that view when the evidence calls for updating. And when people get that balance right, it tends to promote trust, stability, and satisfaction in their relationship. And as we've discussed before, can even have positive effects on how the partner feels about us and how they treat us.
在情况模棱两可时，假设对方出于善意而不是恶意。但与此同时，保持对新信息的开放态度也很重要。因此，如果出现了一致的令人不安的行为模式，你可不想将其归咎于别的原因而忽视它。事实上，这就是为什么有些人最终会留在那些对他们真的很不好的关系中。所以这其实是一个平衡的问题。既要对伴侣保持总体上积极的看法，又要在有证据表明需要更新这种看法时及时更新。当人们把这种平衡拿捏得恰到好处时，它往往能促进关系中的信任、稳定和满意度。正如我们以前讨论过的，这甚至会对伴侣对我们的感觉以及他们对待我们的方式产生积极的影响。
So let's unpack this a little bit. Let's start with the idea of positive illusion. This idea has been around for a very long time. Talk for a moment about how positive illusions about our partner can be a good thing for our relationships. Positive illusions can be a good thing for our relationships because it helps us have the sense that the person that we've committed to is the right person for us. It can help alleviate doubts that many of us would otherwise have regarding whether we've made the right choice or not. And so that can promote a sense of satisfaction with the relationship. And then that sense of satisfaction can in turn affect how we behave toward the partner, can make us feel committed to that partner and engage in a variety of behavior.
所以让我们来剖析一下这一点。让我们从积极错觉（positive illusion）的概念开始。这个概念已经存在很长时间了。请花一点时间谈谈，关于伴侣的积极错觉如何对我们的关系有益。积极错觉对我们的关系有好处，因为它有助于让我们觉得，我们所承诺一生的人就是最适合我们的人。它可以帮助减轻我们许多人在其他情况下会产生的怀疑，即我们是否做出了正确的选择。因此，这可以提升对关系的满意度。而这种满意度反过来又会影响我们对待伴侣的方式，让我们对伴侣做出承诺，并参与各种各样的行为，
that help create the positive relationship that we want. In addition, like the self-fulfilling prophecy we talked about before, it can have an effect on the partners. So the partners may have more positive experiences with us when we entertain these positive illusions. And the partner's feeling of satisfaction in turn can result in them behaving in the positive way that we perceived initially. I mean, in some ways, this is the idea that if you give someone a good reputation, they have some incentive to live up to that good reputation.
从而帮助建立我们想要的积极关系。此外，就像我们之前讨论过的自我实现的预言一样，它会对伴侣产生影响。因此，当我们心存这些积极错觉时，伴侣可能会与我们有更多积极的体验。而伴侣的满意感反过来又会促使他们表现出我们最初感知到的那种积极行为。我的意思是，从某种程度上讲，这个观点就是，如果你给一个人一个好的名声，他们就会有一些动力去维护那个好名声。
Yes, that's correct. They might feel that they should live up to the positive views that you have of them, but they also might feel more valued by us. And we know that when people feel valued by others, it provides a strong incentive to reciprocate with positive behaviors. intentions in return. It's very striking that I think many of us, of course, imagine that, you know, our thoughts and our feelings come first, and then our behaviors come from our thoughts and feelings. And that certainly is true to some extent. But I think what you're also saying is that if you start with the behaviors, if you start
是的，没错。他们可能会觉得自己应该不辜负你对他们的积极看法，但他们也可能会觉得我们更珍视他们。我们知道，当人们感到自己被他人珍视时，这会提供强有力的动力，让他们用积极的行为和意图来进行回报。非常引人注目的是，我想我们很多人当然都会想象，你知道，我们的思想和感受是先发生的，然后我们的行为才源于我们的思想和感受。这在某种程度上当然是真的。但我认为你同时也在说，如果你从行为开始，如果你从
by acting loving, you, in fact, start to feel loving. Yes, that's correct. When we act loving, we sort of create behavioral evidence for why we should be valued in our relationship and why we have a good relationship. And that can override some of these negative expectations that we bring to the relationship. A reminder, ask yourself if you have projected your feelings and attitudes onto someone else, or if someone has projected their own views onto you. If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone.
表现得充满爱意开始，事实上，你就会开始感受到爱。是的，没错。当我们表现得充满爱意时，我们实际上就为“为什么我们在关系中应该被珍视”以及“为什么我们拥有一段美好的关系”创造了行为证据。这可以凌驾于我们带入这段关系的某些消极期望之上。再次提醒，问问自己，你是否曾将自己的感受和态度投射到别人身上，或者是否有人将他们自己的观点投射到了你身上。如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者对本期节目的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。
Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line projections. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Ed, you've noted that the first step to working skillfully with our projections is to be able to see that we're employing them. You recently had an interaction with your wife in which you were able to catch yourself in the act of attributing emotions to her
两三分钟就足够了。请将文件发送至feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写：projections（预测）。再重复一遍，邮箱是feedback@hiddenbrain.org。Ed，你曾指出，巧妙处理我们预测的第一步，是能够看到我们正在使用它们。你最近与妻子有过一次互动，在那次互动中，你抓包了自己将情绪归咎于她的行为，
that were really coming from you. Tell me what happened. and how that interaction unfolded? Sure. There was a moment recently where I felt like my wife was being a little short with me. It was something about her tone,
而这些情绪其实来自于你自己。能告诉我发生了什么，以及那次互动是如何展开的吗？当然。最近有那么一刻，我觉得我妻子对我有点不耐烦。那是关于她的语调什么的，
sort of subtle, and I could feel myself starting to get irritated, and I was on the verge of snapping back. But then I paused and I realized that I've been stressed and on edge all day, and it occurred to me that I might be just reading that into her, seeing her as more agitated than she actually was. So instead of reacting, I just took a step back
有点微妙，我能感觉到自己开始烦躁起来，差一点就冲动地回怼过去。但接着我停顿了一下，我意识到自己一整天都压力山大、神经紧绷，我突然想到，我可能只是把这种状态投射到了她身上，把她看作比实际情况更急躁。所以，我没有做出反应，而是退了一步，
and considered that I might be bringing a particular lens to this interaction and help me reframe the situation as one where she didn't actually seem as upset as I had initially assumed. And moments like that have made me more aware of how easily our internal state can shape what we think we're seeing other people. So now when I feel that kind of strong reaction, I try to treat it as a signal to pause and ask, is this really about them or is this about something that I'm bringing to this interaction?
考虑到我可能带着某种特定视角来看待这次互动，这帮我重新构建了情境，原来她其实并没有我最初想象的那么沮丧。像这样的时刻让我更加意识到，我们的内在状态是多么容易塑造我们眼中所看到的其他人。所以现在，当我感受到那种强烈的反应时，我试着把它当作一个信号，提醒自己停下来问问：这真的是关于他们吗，还是关于我带进这场互动中的某些东西？
One of the things that we find is that in many situations, our partner's behavior is actually a bit ambiguous. There's more than one way to interpret it. And in those moments, we have a choice about the lens that we use. we can lean toward a more negative interpretation or we could have a more generous one. And choosing the more benevolent interpretation, giving your partner the benefit of the doubt, can be really helpful for relationships. It reduces unnecessary conflict and it helps maintain a sense of trust and connection. That said, it's not about ignoring reality.
我们发现的一件事是，在许多情况下，伴侣的行为实际上有点模棱两可。解读它的方式不止一种。而在那些时刻，我们有权选择我们所戴的眼镜。我们可以倾向于更消极的解读，或者我们可以有一个更宽容的解读。选择更仁慈的解读，给予伴侣选择相信的好处，对关系真的很有帮助。它减少了不必要的冲突，并有助于维持信任和连接感。话虽如此，这并不是要忽视现实。
If there's a clear pattern of hurtful behavior, that's something that you want to take seriously. but it's those gray areas, and there are many of them, where leaning toward generosity is often a healthier and more constructive way to see your partner. Edward LeMay is a psychologist at the University of Maryland. Ed, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. This was really great. What Ed is suggesting can be difficult to practice.
如果存在明确的伤害行为模式，那是你需要认真对待的事情。但正是在那些灰色地带——而且有很多这样的灰色地带——倾向于宽容，往往是一种更健康、更具建设性的看待伴侣的方式。爱德华·勒梅（Edward LeMay）是马里兰大学的心理学家。Ed，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。这真的很棒。Ed所建议的事情付诸实践可能会很困难。
Leaning into generosity when your partner is getting under your skin isn't easy. But developing the skill can create a virtuous cycle of connection. It can open the space for our partners to show how much they value us. And being appreciated by the people in our lives is vitally important. Recently, we heard from listener in Kim. She told us that in the days after a surgical procedure, she felt ignored by her family. For context, I live away from home.
当伴侣惹恼你时，去倾向于宽容并不容易。但培养这种技能可以创造一个良性的连接循环。它可以为我们的伴侣腾出空间，让他们展现出他们有多么珍视我们。而被生活中的人们所欣赏至关重要。最近，我们收到了听众金（Kim）的来信。她告诉我们，在做完外科手术后的几天里，她觉得被家人忽视了。作为背景，我住在离家很远的地方。
And I hate to say this, but even if I did live at home, I don't think the outcome would have been much different, but my immediate family did not call to check on me. They knew I had it. Everybody's kind of wrapped up in what they're doing. I do live out of state, and nobody called to check on me. Inkem knows her family cares about her, but she wants that concern expressed through actions.
我讨厌这么说，但即使我真的住在家里，我想结果也不会有什么不同，但我直系亲属没有打电话来关心我。他们知道我做了手术。每个人都忙于他们正在做的事情。我确实住在外州，没有人打电话来关心我。金知道她的家人关心她，但她希望这种关心通过行动表达出来。
Not having anyone to check in with when I arrive somewhere new, like if I'm traveling, just how hands off my family is when it comes to my well-being is just so incredibly hurtful. And I think that one thing I started to do is being the type of person that I would want or the type of friend I would want. So doing those things for other people has kind of help ease that pain. When we treat another person with warmth and love, we hope to see these emotions reflected back to us. What happens when they're not?
当我到达某个新地方时没有人来关心我，比如我在旅行时，我的家人对我的福祉是如此不闻不问，这实在是太令人伤心了。我想我开始做的一件事就是成为我想要的那种人，或者成为我希望拥有的那种朋友。所以为其他人做那些事在某种程度上帮助减轻了那种痛苦。当我们用温暖和爱对待另一个人时，我们希望看到这些情感被反射回我们身上。当它们没有时，会发生什么？
When we come back, listener stories about the psychological importance of feeling loved. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us want to believe that our families and romantic partners love us. but knowing in an intellectual way that someone loves us and feeling that love, those are very different things. At the University of California Riverside, Sonia Lubomirsky studies the human desire to feel loved. With Harry Reese, she is the author of How to Feel Loved, the Five Mindsets That Get You More of What Matters Most. Sonia was a guest on a recent episode of Hidden Brain titled Do You Feel Loved?
稍后回来，听众们讲述关于被爱之感的心理重要性的故事。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。我们所有人都希望相信我们的家人和浪漫伴侣是爱我们的。但在理智上知道某人爱我们与感受到这份爱，那是两码事。在加州大学河滨分校，索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基（Sonia Lyubomirsky）研究人类被爱的渴望。她与哈里·里斯（Harry Reese）合著了《如何被爱：带你获得更多最重要的东西的五种思维模式》（How to Feel Loved, the Five Mindsets That Get You More of What Matters Most）。索尼娅曾是《隐藏的大脑》近期一期题为《你觉得自己被爱吗？》的嘉宾。
Today, she returns to the show for our popular segment, your questions answered. Sonia Lubomirski, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. I'm delighted to be back. Sonia, we all want to be loved. You say that it is vitally important not just to be loved, but to feel loved. Explain this distinction to me. Yeah, I think a lot of us are loved, but we don't feel loved. My co-author, Harry Reese, and I actually conducted a survey expressly for our book.
今天，她再次来到节目中，参加我们广受欢迎的栏目：回答你的问题。索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴再次来到这里。索尼娅，我们都渴望被爱。你说至关重要的不仅是被爱，而且是“感受到被爱”。请向我解释一下这种区别。是的，我认为我们很多人都被爱着，但我们并没有感受到被爱。我的合著者哈里·里斯和我实际上专门为我们的书进行了一项调查。
And we found that 70% said that there's at least one relationship in their life that they don't feel as loved as they'd like to feel. And I like to think of it as kind of like, you know, we all know people who are beautiful but they don't feel beautiful or who are smart, but they don't think they're smart. So similarly, we can be loved but not feel loved. What are the implications of this? What is the consequence of being loved but not feeling loved? Well, I've been doing research on happiness for more than 36 years. And after all those years, I came to the conclusion that really the key to happiness is feeling connected and feeling loved. And so if you don't feel loved, I would argue you can't be truly happy.
我们发现，70%的人表示，他们生活中的至少某一段关系中，他们并没有感到如自己希望的那样被爱。我喜欢这样比喻，你知道的，我们都知道有些人长得很美，但他们并不觉得自己美；或者有些人很聪明，但他们不觉得自己聪明。同样地，我们可能被爱着，却没有感受到被爱。这会带来什么影响？被爱却感受不到被爱，会产生什么后果？嗯，我一直在研究幸福超过36年。在经历了这么多年之后，我得出的结论是，幸福的关键确实在于感到连接和感到被爱。因此，如果你没有感受到被爱，我认为你就无法真正快乐。
So when we feel unloved, the consequences can sometimes be dire. Listener, Tori brings us one such example. She's an infectious disease epidemiologist. And during the COVID-19 pandemic, many of her family members, including her mother and her husband, didn't trust her expertise on the virus and the vaccines created to protect people from it. That was a huge personal affront in some regards as a professional, but their lack of trust in me. It felt like it could only be true that they thought I was stupid because I spent years becoming this professional and they believed everything else I'd ever told them except when it
所以，当我们感到不被爱时，其后果有时可能是可怕的。听众托里（Tori）给我们带来了这样一个例子。她是一名传染病流行病学家。在新冠疫情期间，她的许多家庭成员，包括她的母亲和丈夫，都不信任她关于病毒以及为保护人们免受其害而开发的疫苗的专业知识。从某种职业角度来看，这是一种巨大的个人侮辱，但他们对我的不信任。感觉这只能说明一件事，那就是他们认为我很愚蠢，因为我花了多年时间成为这个领域的专业人士，而且除了在
came to COVID. And they told me outright that they did not think I was stupid, that they loved me. but I couldn't believe that. And it led to the end of my marriage. And I was able to thankfully repair my relationship with my mother, but that took a lot of work. And there will always be some scars there, I think, because it is one of the most painful experiences in the world when people who you believe love you show you that they don't.
COVID这件事上，他们相信我告诉过他们的所有其他事情。他们直截了当地告诉我，他们不认为我很愚蠢，他们是爱我的。但我无法相信这一点。这导致了我的婚姻破裂。值得庆幸的是，我修复了与母亲的关系，但这需要付出很多努力。我想那里永远都会有一些伤疤，因为当那些你相信爱你的人向你展示他们不爱时，这是世界上最痛苦的经历之一。
So Sonia, some people might hear the story and think, Tori's family told her they loved her, just because they disagreed with her about COVID, It doesn't mean they didn't love her. But what I take away from Tori's story is that for her, this was not just an intellectual affront, but an emotional affront. And I'm not sure it's anyone else's place to tell Tori what she needs to feel loved. Talk for a moment, if you will, about how we might all have idiosyncratic ways of feeling loved.
所以索尼娅，有些人听到这个故事可能会想，托里的家人告诉过她他们爱她，仅仅因为他们在COVID问题上与她意见不分歧不代表他们不爱她。但我从托里的故事中汲取到的是，对她来说，这不仅是一次理智上的侮辱，更是一次情感上的侮辱。而且我不确定其他人是否有资格告诉托里她需要什么才能感受到被爱。如果你愿意，请花一点时间谈谈，为什么我们所有人对于被爱可能都有着独特的奇特方式。
You know, Tori's question is almost heartbreaking, right? And it shows that just because someone tells you they love you or tells you, oh, I don't think you're stupid, it doesn't necessarily come through. It's like we all have a cup of love and people can pour love in that cup, but it might not be getting in or might be leaking out for various reasons. And I guess the bottom light I'm taking from Tori's story
你知道，托里的问题几乎让人心碎，对吧？它表明，仅仅因为某人告诉你他们爱你，或者告诉你“哦，我不认为你蠢”，这种爱并不一定能传递过来。这就像我们所有人都有一个装爱的杯子，人们可以把爱倒进那个杯子里，但由于种种原因，它可能没有真正进去，或者可能正在漏掉。我想我从托里的故事中得出的底线是，
is that somehow she wasn't feeling seen. She wasn't really, they weren't really understanding. She wasn't feeling understood, understanding what she's all about. And we argue in our book that the key to feeling loved is really to be known, right? to be heard and seen and understood, and she was not feeling seen and understood.
不知何故，她没有感受到被看见。她并没有真正……他们没有真正理解她。她没有感受到被理解——理解她到底是一个什么样的人。我们在书中认为，感到被爱的关键实际上是被了解，对吧？被倾听、被看见、被理解，而她并没有感受到被看见和被理解。
I mean, for her, being a scientist was clearly a large part of her identity. And for her, it sounds like being unloved was a consequence of people not recognizing that identity. Exactly. That's like when people don't really see what's inside of you that really matters to you. So feeling known is when you sort of, when you look at yourself and what do you see that really matters to you? Like, who do you really see yourself to be? and for her being an epidemiologist was that important part of her identity. And so they weren't really seeing that important part of her
我的意思是，对她来说，作为一个科学家显然是她身份认同很大的一部分。对她来说，听起来不被爱是因为人们没有认可那种身份认同。正是如此。这就好比人们并没有真正看到你内心深处对你来说真正重要、真正在乎的东西。所以，感到被了解是指，当你审视自己时，你看到了什么对你真正重要的东西？比如，你真正认为自己是一个什么样的人？而对她来说，成为一名流行病学家就是她身份中至关重要的那一部分。所以他们并没有真正看到她的那重要一部分，
and seeing how much it matters to her. And so, yeah, it's hard to feel loved when people aren't really seeing you. So sometimes there are big disagreements that can leave us feeling unloved, but other times we can feel undervalued in small moments. Here's listener Leila with one such story. My partner right now, we were riding the bus together the other day. It was hot. They were in a packed bus who were standing body to body and a seat opened up. And immediately, my partner took the seat. They didn't offer it to me. They didn't consider that I also might be hot and wanting to sit down.
也没有看到这对她有多么重要。所以，是的，当人们没有真正看到你时，你很难感受到被爱。因此，有时会有一些重大分歧让我们感到不被爱，但有时我们也会在微小的时刻中感到被低估。听众莱拉（Leila）给我们带来了这样一个故事。我现在的伴侣，前几天我们一起坐公交车。天气很热。车里挤满了人，大家都身体贴着身体，这时空出一个座位。我的伴侣立刻坐上了那个座位。他们没有把它让给我。他们没有考虑到我也可能觉得热并想要坐下。
And if they had offered it to me, I probably would have said no. But I don't know. I think I felt unloved in that moment. because I wasn't considered. Sonia, can you talk about how small acts can sometimes represent so much to us? Yes, in fact, when Harry Wiese and I asked people what it is that makes people feel loved, a lot of the examples were small things. They were like, that person, they handed me a cup of tea before they, I even knew that I wanted that cup of tea, right? They sort of, as Layla mentioned, sort of being considered.
如果他们把它让给我，我可能还会说不。但，我不知道。我想我在那一刻感到了不被爱，
And, you know, one thing we talk about in our book, is called the open-heart mindset, which is this idea that we show warmth and compassion and kindness towards the other person. We believe and then we want them to be happy, right? So in this moment on the bus where her partner was not showing the open-heart mindset towards her, no sort of that small moments of warmth, you know, compassion, like, I want you to be happy, you know, putting them as a priority beyond themselves. And of course, the striking thing here is that it's not the seat on the bus itself. That's the point. You know, this. It's, I mean, it's entirely possible that Leila might have said, no, no, thank you.
因为我没有被考虑到。索尼娅，你能谈谈为什么微小的行为有时能代表我们内心如此多的东西吗？是的，事实上，当哈里·里斯和我问人们是什么让他们感到被爱时，很多例子都是小事。它们就像是：那个人，他在我甚至都不知道自己想要一杯茶之前，就递给我了一杯茶，对吧？他们那种——正如莱拉提到的——被人放在心上的感觉。而且，你知道，我们在书里讨论的一件事，叫做“敞开心扉的心态”（open-heart mindset），也就是这种理念：我们对另一个人表现出温暖、同情和善良。我们相信，并且我们希望他们快乐，对吧？所以在公交车上的那一刻，她的伴侣没有对她展现出敞开心扉的心态，没有那种充满温暖的小瞬间，没有同情，比如“我希望你快乐”，把对方放在自己之前。当然，这里引人注目的一点是，重点并不是公交车上的那个座位本身。你知道的，这。我的意思是，完全有可能的是，如果莱拉被让座了，她可能会说“不，谢谢，请您继续坐吧”。是“没有被让座”这一事实，成为了痛苦的来源。是的，exactly。这种被人放在心上的感觉，缺乏这种被考虑的感觉。是的，那是那种温暖和善良的信号，以及“我希望你快乐”的感觉，而我们正是需要这些。它甚至都不需要真正发生，
Please keep sitting. If the seat had been offered to her, it was the fact that it was not offered. That was the source of pain. Yeah, exactly. This sort of being considered, lack of being considered. Yeah, it's the signal of that warmth and kindness. And, like, I want you to be happy that we need. It doesn't even have to play out.
只要那个信号存在并被表达出来就行。索尼娅，我们来谈谈这种“不被爱的感觉”可能从何而来。几位听众说，他们在童年时期就感到了不被爱。这是马里奥（Mario）的故事。我在上小学时步行上下学。从来没有人想过给我一把进屋的钥匙。我是家里第一个到家的，因为大家都在工作。所以我想出了各种方法来撬门进屋。
It's just the signal is there and is being expressed. Sonia, let's talk about where the feeling of being unloved can come from. several listeners said they felt unloved when they were children. Here's Mario. I was in elementary school and I walked home from school. And no one ever thought to give me a key to get into the house. I was the first one home because everyone was working. So I found different ways to break into the house.
而且，比如，我从来没有一个长辈问过我：你今天过得怎么样？你的家庭作业怎么样？你知道，你需要什么帮助吗，诸如此类的事情。我记得自己只是，你知道，不得不一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地重读一本书，往前翻好几页去试图弄懂它。所以在某种程度上，也许这对我的人生有帮助，因为我能相当轻松地把事情搞定。但是，你知道，当时我谁也没有。我也讨厌家长会，因为我知道第二天老师会问：你的父母在哪里？我只能编个借口，因为我知道根本不会有人去。
Also, like, I never had a parent figure ask me, how was your day? How was your homework? You know, do you need help with anything, any of that stuff? I remember just, you know, having to reread and read and read and read the book, go back pages to try to figure it out. So in some ways, maybe that has helped me in my life because I can figure things out pretty easily. But, you know, then I didn't have anybody. I also hated parent-teacher conferences because I knew the next day the teacher would be like, where were your parents? And I would just make up an excuse because I just knew no one would go.
而且我在成年生活中依然带着很多这种感觉。所以索尼娅，我很为马里奥感到难过，童年时感到不被爱与成年后感到不被爱之间有什么联系吗？是的，哇，这让我非常感动。嗯，当然，你知道，我虽然不是发展心理学家，但依恋风格确实植根于童年，对吧？因此，那些不安全型依恋的人，无论是回避型还是焦虑型，往往都植根于童年，源于这些童年经历。
and I still feel have a lot of that in my adult life. So Sonia, I feel for Mario, is there a link between feeling unloved in childhood and feeling unloved later in life? Yeah, wow, this is really moving to me. Well, absolutely, you know, I'm not a developmental psychologist, but certainly attachment styles are rooted in childhood, right? So people who are insecurely attached, whether they're avoidant or anxious, often are rooted in childhood, these kinds of childhood experience.
这可能是一个原因。有很多很多原因导致我们没有内化或者说没有把那种爱吸收进来。所以再说一次，当我们拥有那种爱的杯子，人们把爱倒进杯子里时，但出于某种原因我们不信任它，部分原因可能与我们的童年模式、习惯以及我们所学到的东西有关。部分原因只是我们在童年时从未学会真正爱自己。而现在我们并不真正爱自己。当我们不爱自己时，别人是能察觉到的。如果我们不认为自己真正值得被爱，我们就不会真正相信别人给的爱是真诚的。所以再次强调，这其实不是我的专业领域，但我确实对爱为什么难以进入内心有一些看法。但从某种程度上说，索尼娅，你实际上是在提出一个双重的问题，对吧？一个问题可能是我们没有被爱，或者没有以我们希望被爱的方式被爱；但你同时也在说第二个问题，你知道，在某种程度上我们可能有一个“故障的测温仪”。你知道，由于我们自己的滤镜和偏见，我们实际上并没有按照爱流向我们的方式去记录它。
That could be one reason. There's just so many reasons why we are not internalizing or sort of taking that love in. So again, when we have sort of that cup of love and people are pouring love into the cup, but for some reason we don't trust it, some of that could be with our childhood patterns and habits and what we've learned. Some of it is just that we never learned to really love ourselves when we were children. And now we don't really love ourselves. When we don't love ourselves, other people can pick up on that. We don't really trust other people's love is genuine. If we don't think we're really truly lovable. And so again, this is not really my area of expertise, but I certainly have some ideas for how that love has trouble getting in. But in some ways, what you're doing is you're laying out effectively a two-pronged problem here, Sonia, which is one problem might be that we're not being loved or not being loved in the way we want to be loved. But you're also saying the second problem is, you know, we might have, in some ways, a faulty meter. You know, we're not actually registering things in the way that it's coming to us because of our own filters and our own biases.
是的，完全正确。正如我所提到的，我认为有很多原因或好几个原因。你提到了两个主要原因，为什么那种爱不知何故没有进入内心，对吧？那个故障的测温仪，也许我们真的没有被爱，你知道，或者也许我们在某种程度上没有意识到它。我们不信任它。我们没有在正确的地方寻找它。你知道，其实哈里·里斯和我在书中驳斥了“爱的语言”（love languages）的概念。然而，“爱的语言”其实是一个很好的启发式工具。
Yeah, absolutely. As I mentioned, I think there could be many reasons or several reasons. You're mentioning two main ones, why that love is somehow not getting in, right? The faulty meter, maybe we really aren't loved, you know, or maybe we somehow aren't aware of it. We're not trusting it. We're not looking for it in the right places. You know, we actually, Harry Reese and I kind of debunk the idea of the love languages in our book. And yet, the love language is actually a good heuristic.
而且，我有一个这样的例子：我曾和一个通过邮件给我寄礼物的人约会，寄来一些带有手写便条的可爱小礼物，这很可爱。但我并没有感受到爱，因为我真正从他那里需要的是肯定的言辞（words of affirmation）。我们需要某种言辞上的表达，或者以某种方式花时间陪我——高质量的陪伴。但他的爱的语言是礼物，你知道的。所以这种情况也可能发生在其他人身上，我们没有把其他人对爱的表达解读为爱，因为我们在寻找别的东西。我在想，其中一部分原因是否也是因为，你知道，索尼娅，我们都生活在一个有着七八十亿其他人口的星球上。在某种程度上，你知道，感觉我们只是这个庞大、无差别的群体的一部分。而如果有人对你说“不，你不是芸芸众生中的一个，
And sort of, I have this example where I was dating someone who would send me gifts in the mail, like little cute gifts with little handwritten notes, which is adorable. But yet I wasn't feeling love because what I really needed from him were words of affirmation. We're sort of saying something or spending time with me in a certain way quality time. But his love language was gifts, you know. And so that could be with other people, too, that we're not sort of interpreting other people's expressions of love as love because we're looking for something else. And I'm wondering if some of this is also because, you know, Sonia, we're all walking around on a planet with, you know, seven or eight billion other people. And at some level, you know, it feels like we are part of this big undifferentiated mass. And it helps to have someone say, you know, no, you're not one of many.
你是独一无二的一个”，这会很有帮助。正是如此。而且我看见你，我听见你。这就是为什么当人们对我们表现出好奇心时——对我们的热情、我们生活的细节，以及那些我们可能感兴趣但其他人并不感兴趣的无聊小事。当人们真正看到我们的兴趣、价值观和热情时，这是一种礼物，对吧。稍后回来，当你爱一个人，但他们不爱你时，你该怎么办？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。
You're one of one. Exactly. And I see you and I hear you, which is why when people show curiosity in us, you know, in our passions and the details of our lives and like the boring little things that we might be interested in. but no one else is. It's a gift, right, when people really see our interests and our values and our passions. When we come back, what do you do when you love someone, but they don't love you back? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
你可以在一个拥挤的房间里感到孤独，或者在一段持续数十年的婚姻中感到不被爱。当孤独感最强烈时，往往就是这个时候：你身边有很多人，但你的关系却无法让你感到满足。在一项针对近2000名美国人的调查中，三分之二的人表示，他们渴望在生活中被周围的人更多地爱。心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基就是该调查的作者之一。她认为，问题不在于我们有多少朋友，
You can feel alone in a crowded room, or you can feel unloved in a decades-long marriage. That's often when loneliness strikes the hardest, when you have people around you, but your relationships don't feel satisfying. In a survey of nearly 2,000 Americans, two and three people said they yearn to feel more loved by the people in their lives. The psychologist Sonia Lubomirski was one of the authors of that survey. She argues that the problem isn't the number of friends we have
也不在于我们的社交日程有多空旷。问题在于，太多的互动并没有让我们感受到真正的被爱。索尼娅，你刚才告诉我，你对“爱的语言”这个概念持怀疑态度，也就是我们所有人都希望别人以某种特殊方式与我们沟通的观点。而且你说这并没有得到科学证据的充分支持。请多谈谈这一点。爱的语言这个理论有什么问题？当然，当然。
or how empty our social calendars are. It's that too often, our interactions don't leave us feeling genuinely loved. You told me earlier, Sonia, that you're skeptical about the idea of love languages, the idea that we all have these special ways that we want to be communicated to and with. And that you say that's not quite supported by the scientific evidence. Say more about this. What's the problem with the theory of love languages? Sure, sure.
嗯，我首先应该说，我其实很喜欢爱的语言这个概念。我一直在谈论它们。不受支持的首先是“只有五种”这个观点。爱的语言有很多种。事实证明，我们所有人真正都渴望的其实只有两种爱的语言。那就是肯定的言辞（words of affirmation）和高质量的陪伴（quality time）。因此，我们大家基本上都渴望这两种爱的语言。另一个发现是，某人通过越多爱的语言向你表达爱，效果就越好。
Well, I should start by saying I love the idea of love languages. I talk about them all the time. What's not supported, first of all the idea that there's just five. There's lots of love languages. It also turns out there's really two love languages that we all want. And those are words of affirmation and quality time. and so we kind of all want those love languages. Another finding is that really the more love languages someone shows love to you, the better.
所以，真正不被证据支持的那部分是“匹配假说”（matching hypothesis），也就是这种观点：如果你找到了一个其爱的语言与你匹配的人，对吧？比如，我的爱的语言是身体接触，而他们也是以这种方式向我表达爱。那么这将带来一段更强大、更持久的关系。这部分其实是不被支持的。所以匹配并不是真的那么重要。只是你用越多的爱的语言来表达你的爱，就会越好。因此，我对你之爱的体验，可能与你实际对我感受到的爱大不相同。
And so the part that's really not supported by the evidence is that there's sort of this matching hypothesis, the idea that if you find someone who matches your love language, right? Like my love language is physical touch and that's what they express the love to me in the most. Then that's going to lead to a stronger and more long-lasting relationship. That's the part that's really not support. So the matching is not really that important. It's just sort of the more love languages you express your love in, the better. So my experience of your love might be very different than the love that you actually feel for me.
我们听到了听众凯瑟琳（Kathleen）的一个故事，它印证了这一点。我是一个注重行动的人，我会通过为我爱的人做一些小事来向他们表明我在乎他们，为他们做饭、给他们留便条等等。我13年前经历了一次离婚。在我疗愈的过程中，我发现我从未真正在婚姻中感受到被爱。我被告知“我爱你，我爱你”，但行动从来没有跟上。快进到2026年的母亲节，我收到了一条短信，因为我的孩子住在外州：你是一位最棒的母亲，没有你，我就不会成为现在的自己。然而我得知他们和他们的父亲以及父亲的家人一起庆祝了母亲节。
We heard a story from listener Kathleen that speaks to this idea. I am an action-oriented person in that I will show the person that I love that I care for them by doing little things for them, making them meals, leaving them notes, etc. I went through a divorce 13 years ago. and one of the things I uncovered during my healing journey was that I never really felt loved in my marriage. I was told, I love you, I love you, but the actions never matched. Fast forward to Mother's Day of 26 and the text message that comes in because my child lives out of state, you're the most wonderful mother, I wouldn't be half the person I am without you. But yet I learned that they celebrated Mother's Day with their father and their father's family.
这就是我感到不被爱的方式，当人们告诉我他们爱我，但他们的行动却向我表明并非如此。所以，索尼娅，你在凯瑟琳的故事中听到了什么？这真的就是爱的语言的例子，对她来说，行动比言语更有力量。对其他人来说，则是言语。比如，对我来说，言语更有分量。听到孩子说的话——“你是有史以来最伟大的母亲，我绝不会选择另一个母亲”——我觉得内心无比温暖，我心想，哇，这正是我希望从我孩子那里听到的话。事实上，我女儿也给我发过非常类似的短信，她写道：无论我们怎么吵架，我都绝不会要求换一个母亲。
This is how I have not felt loved, is when people tell me they love me, but their actions show me otherwise. So, Sonia, what do you hear in Kathleen's story? It's really the love language's example, that for her, it's really actions that speak louder than words. For other people, it's words. Like, for me, it's the words that speak louder. heard what the child said, you're the greatest mother ever, I would never choose another mother. Like, I felt so heart-worned by that. I thought, wow, that is what I'd want to hear for my child. And actually, I had a very similar message for my daughter who wrote something like I would never, even when we fight, I would never ask for another mother.
不管怎样，对我来说这简直是……我其实正在读它。它现在就摆在我面前。我希望你知道这一点。无论我们为什么事争吵，我都绝不会要求换一个母亲。这是我15岁的孩子写的。无论如何，所以这才是真正温暖我的心、让我感到被爱的东西。但对凯瑟琳来说，是行动，对吧？行动对她来说比言语更有力量。所以部分原因让我感到难过，因为那些家庭成员可能非常非常爱她，但他们只是没有以她真正需要接受的方式表现出来。也许关键在于，也许解决办法就是去沟通。
Anyway, to me that's literally, I actually reading it. It's actually right in front of me. I hope you know that. Whatever we fight about, I would never ask for another mother. This is my 15-year-old. But anyway, so that's what really warms my heart and makes me feel love. But for Kathleen, it's actions, right? Actions speak louder to her than words. And so part of me makes me sad because those family members might really love her very much, but they're just sort of not showing it the way that she really needs to receive. And maybe the key is, maybe the solution is to communicate that.
你知道，就是去表达：这正是我感受到被爱所真正需要的。那种认为“当人们爱我们时，他们就应该知道、就应该能猜到我们需要什么”的想法。然而，事实并非如此。你知道，我们真的不会读心术。所以我们需要向彼此传达这些需求。是的。所以我们讨论了从他人那里感受到爱，但几位听众打电话来发表了关于“爱自己”的评论。泰勒（Taylor）说，在她的青少年时期，她其实很讨厌自己，但经过多年对这些严苛情绪的调整，她来到了一个更好的地方。
You know, it's to say that this is what I really need to feel loved. This idea that when people love us, they should just know, they should just be able to guess what we need. And yet, that's just not the case. You know, we really can't read people's minds. And so we need to communicate those needs to each other. Yeah. So we've discussed feeling love from others, but a few listeners called in with comments about loving themselves. Taylor says that in her teens, she actually hated herself, but after years of working on those harsh feelings, she's come to be in a better place.
这是她的原话。你知道，我已经到了这样一个地步：我不再那么讨厌自己了。要么我喜欢自己，要么我感觉很中立，这很棒。但现在我的新问题是，既然我喜欢自己、接纳自己，我反而觉得周围的人——正如你所说，我的社区——对我的喜欢和爱变少了。这真是一个可怕的悖论：现在我已经克服了讨厌自己的想法，而实际上，自我感觉在讨厌自己时，我反而觉得被其他人更多地爱着。现在角色完全对调了。
Here she is. You know, I've come to a place where I don't feel so much like I dislike myself. I either like myself or I feel neutral, and that's great. But now my new problem is now that I like myself and accept myself, I feel less liked and less loved by those around me, by just like you said, by my community. And this is just such a horrible paradox that now that I've gotten over the idea of hating myself, And actually, I felt like I was more loved by other people when I hated myself. And now the roles have completely reversed.
现在我正在接受心理治疗，以便在个人和集体层面上感受到生活中的人们给予我更多的爱。所以我现在是在笑着说这件事，但在日常生活中，这非常具有挑战性，也是一个非常棘手的问题。而且，你知道，我听到了所有关于这方面的建议。我觉得我试过了，但不管用。总之，非常感谢。所以，索尼娅，一句经典的名言说，你需要先爱自己，别人才能爱你的。你如何看待泰勒的评论？有一种经典的观点认为，你需要先爱自己，才能感受到被爱或爱别人。
And now I'm in therapy to feel more loved by the people in my life individually and collectively. So I'm laughing about it now, but on an everyday basis, it is very challenging and a very sticky issue. And, you know, I'm hearing all the advice about it. And I feel like I'm trying it and it's not working. Anyway, thank you so much. So, Sonia, the classic saying goes that you need to love yourself before anyone else can love you. What do you make of Taylor's comments? There's this classic idea that you need to love yourself before you can feel loved or love others.
我其实并不认同这一点。我认为因果关系其实是双向的，对吧？比如，是的，当你爱自己时，从他人那里感受到爱会更容易，也更有可能。但同时，你也是在爱的关系背景下去学习如何爱自己的。所以我必须指出这一点。泰勒的问题，太有趣了。这让我想到，也许现在她更爱自己了，她反而对她所看到的“爱的缺失”有了更多觉察。
I actually don't agree with that. I believe the causality is really bidirectional, right? Like, yes, it's easier to feel love from others and it's more likely when you love yourself. but also you learn to love yourself in the context of love relationships. So I do want to say that. Taylor's problem, it's so interesting. It made me think that maybe now that she loves herself more, she's more aware of the lack of love that she sees.
我其实并不同意这一点。我认为因果关系实际上是双向的，对吧？就像，是的，当你爱自己的时候，更容易感受到来自他人的爱，也更有可能感受到；但同时，你也是在爱的关系中学会爱自己的。所以我确实想说，泰勒的问题太有趣了。这让我想到，也许现在她更爱自己了，她反而更能察觉到她所看到的爱的缺失。
It's as though she realizes that she deserves more love. When we don't love ourselves, we're kind of, we don't feel like we deserve it as much. So like, you know, two units of love is sort of enough for us. There's a very old theory in social psychology called self-verification theory where we search for evidence to verify our views of ourselves, including negative views, right? So if we don't feel like we're so lovable, then we don't feel like, you know, we deserve that love. But now that she knows she does deserve it, now she realizes sort of the two units aren't enough,
就好像她意识到自己值得更多的爱。当我们不爱自己的时候，我们基本上，就会觉得我们没那么值得被爱。所以，你知道，两单位的爱对我们来说就差不多够了。社会心理学中有一个非常古老的理论叫做自我验证理论，即我们寻找证据来验证我们对自己的看法，包括消极的看法，对吧？所以如果我们觉得自己不那么讨人喜欢，那我们就不会觉得自己，你知道，配得上那种爱。但现在她知道自己确实配得上，现在她意识到那种两单位的爱不够了，
you know, then it's not enough. What strikes me is that she said that previously when she, quote, unquote, hated herself, she experienced more love from others. And I'm wondering if it's almost like a contrast effect, you know, that people were showing her more love because they saw that she was being so cruel to herself. But now that she's being kinder to herself, people are saying, you know, she's good. She's providing herself with the security she needs. Yeah, I had the same thought too, Shanker. Yes, as though she doesn't need it. I'm also reminded of like people who are sort of fairly like, you know, have good social networks
你知道的，那就真的不够了。让我震惊的是，她说以前当她“引述”自己讨厌自己时，她从别人那里体验到了更多的爱。我想知道这是否有点像反差效应，你知道的，人们向她展示更多的爱，是因为他们看到她对自己太残忍了。但现在她对自己更好了，人们却在说，你知道的，她很好。她正在为自己提供所需的安全性。是的，我有过同样的看法，香卡。是的，就好像她不需要似的。这也让我想起那些，你知道的，拥有不错的社交网络
and lots of friends are fairly successful. They don't actually get a lot of support or compliments. It's as though people feel like they don't need it. They don't need it. And of course, we all need it. We all need that kind of validation and the compliments and the support. We've talked previously on the show about how one way of attracting love is to be loving. This idea in some ways calls to mind the norm of reciprocity that we feel an obligation to return attention and acts of kindness. Many listeners called in about that.
以及很多朋友、相当成功的人。他们实际上并没有得到太多的支持或赞美。就好像人们觉得他们不需要一样。他们不需要。当然，我们都需要。我们都需要那种认可、赞美和支持。我们之前在节目中讨论过，吸引爱的一种方法就是去爱。某种程度上，这种想法让人想起互惠规范，即我们感到有义务回报注意力和善意。许多听众打来电话谈论这一点。
Here's one message we received from listener, AJ. My question is, how do you deal with the feeling of pouring love into other people and not getting it in return? I hear from my students and my friends and members of my community, how meaningful my support is and I'm always there for them. And I remember to ask them questions and follow up and give them insight. And I am thankful to be able to be that person, but simultaneously, I don't feel I received that back. So, Sonia, when we feel like we're loving someone else but not feeling any love in return, what do you suggest we do? This happens sometimes.
这是我们收到的一位听众 AJ 的留言。我的问题是，当你把爱倾注给其他人却得不到回报时，你该如何应对？我从我的学生、朋友以及社区成员那里听到，我的支持是多么有意义，我总是陪伴着他们。我记得问他们问题、跟进并给他们见解。我很感激能够成为那样的人，但与此同时，我觉得我没有得到回报。所以，索尼娅，当我们觉得自己爱别人却感觉不到任何爱的回报时，你建议我们怎么做？这种情况有时会发生。
You feel like you're doing all the right things. Like in our book, we talk about, you know, the importance of sharing and listening and showing curiosity and being attuned to people with warmth and acceptance. And sometimes people, you're doing all those right things. You're showing kindness. You're listening. And the other person is not reciprocating. You know how therapists don't ever tell you kind of directly what they think, right? They want you to come up with the answer.
你觉得自己做了所有正确的事。就像在我们的书中，我们讨论的，你知道的，分享、倾听、表现出好奇心、以热情和接纳与人同频的重要性。有时人们，你做对了所有这些事。你表现出善意。你在倾听。而另一个人却没有回报。你知道心理学家从不直接告诉你他们的想法，对吧？他们希望你自己得出答案。
I'm not a therapist, so I'll be blunt. When people say that to me, I'll say, you know, maybe you made the wrong decision. Maybe you need to step away from that person. Maybe you need to pause that relationship or just accept it, right? If it's a family member, you can't really walk away. So, yeah, if you're trying everything, you're doing all the right things and they're still not reciprocating, you know, again, my blunt response is like maybe it's not going to happen. But most of the time people do reciprocate.
我不是心理学家，所以我会直言不讳。当人们对我这么说时，我会说，你知道，也许你做了错误的决定。也许你需要远离那个人。也许你需要暂停这段关系，或者只是接受它，对吧？如果是一个家庭成员，你真的无法一走了之。所以，是的，如果你尝试了一切，你做了所有正确的事，而他们仍然没有回报，你知道，再次强调，我的直截了当的回答是，也许这不会发生了。但大多数时候人们确实会回报。
But sometimes happens, it's sad, but we might need to just take a pause. One aspect of relationships is that they change over time. So with our romantic partners, we start out in a honeymoon period, as they say, and we're head over heels in love. And then with time that love often matures and evolves. Now, we often expect our partners to remain the same person we fell in love with. But, of course, they are growing and changing, just like we are. Listener, Krista has been with her partner for nine years.
但有时也会发生，这很悲伤，但我们可能需要按下暂停键。关系的一个方面是它们会随着时间而改变。因此，对于我们的浪漫伴侣，我们从蜜月期开始，正如他们所说，我们深深地陷入爱河。然后随着时间的推移，这种爱往往会成熟和演变。现在，我们经常期望我们的伴侣保持我们坠入爱河时的那个人。但是，当然，他们也在成长和改变，就像我们一样。听众克里斯塔和她的伴侣在一起九年了。
At the start of the relationship, they mutually agreed they would not use drugs and alcohol. Here's Krista. We've had a really great life together. Last month, she announced that she wanted to start taking substances again, both medicinally and recreationally. But it was really an announcement that she was going to make this change and very little acknowledgement that this would be a very difficult. challenging juncture for us. So not only am I not feeling loved by her not acknowledging any of that, but I'm also feeling rejected and scared about what's ahead. So my question is, when can one feel loved through a conversation? And when is it hard to close that gap in a conversation? Because
在关系开始时，他们共同同意不使用毒品和酒精。这是克里斯塔。我们一起度过了非常棒的生活。上个月，她宣布她想再次开始接触成瘾物质，既有药用的也有娱乐性的。但这实际上是一个公告，宣告她将做出这种改变，却几乎没有承认这将是一个非常艰难、充满挑战的转折点。因此，不仅因为她没有承认这一切而让我感觉不到她的爱，我还感到被拒绝，并对未来感到害怕。所以我的问题是，什么时候人们可以通过对话感受到爱？什么时候又很难在对话中弥合这种差距？因为
really, it's a shift in values. And how might that play into it? it. Oh, so interesting, so interesting, because it's true, you know, people do change over time, even though we often don't want our partners to change. I'm a big believer in communication and conversation, sort of that, you know, showing curiosity, you know, radical curiosity towards the person who wants to use substances, for example, you know, what is it, what is it, do you think that, you know, why do you want to do this more, you know? Is there something that's missing in your life? I'm actually, I'm a big fan of substances, so I don't necessarily think it has to be a negative, but to this person it was.
真的，这是价值观的转变。这可能会在其中起到什么作用？哦，太有趣了，太有趣了，因为这是真的，你知道，人们确实会随着时间而改变，尽管我们经常不希望我们的伴侣改变。我非常相信沟通和对话，那种，你知道的，表现出好奇心，你知道的，对想要使用成瘾物质的人表现出彻底的好奇心，例如，你知道，这是什么，你认为，你知道，你为什么想这样做更多，你知道吗？你的生活中是不是缺少了什么？实际上，我很喜欢成瘾物质，所以我并不认为它一定是个负面因素，但对这个人来说它是。
So, yeah, showing curiosity really talking about it. And they still might end up feeling like, no, we're really have different values at this point. But they would at least understand each other better. But rather than just making an assumption like, well, this is not what we agreed on, so therefore we shouldn't do it. But really to sort of discuss, like, what has changed for you over time? You know, why is it that you're interested in this? So again, maybe it may seem obvious to sort of, but really it's again getting back to like really knowing and understanding the other person. and for them to really know and understand you,
所以，是的，表现出好奇心，真正地去谈论它。而他们最终可能还是会觉得，不，我们在这一点上真的有不同的价值观。但他们至少能更好地理解彼此。而不是仅仅做出假设，比如，嗯，这不是我们商量好的，所以我们不应该这样做。而是真正去讨论，比如，随着时间的推移，你身上有什么改变了？你知道，为什么你对这个感兴趣？所以再次强调，这可能看起来很显眼，但实际上还是回归到真正了解和理解对方。为了让他们真正了解和理解你，
why is it sort of threatening or upsetting for you that you're making this change and really having that communication, that two-way communication, I think, is always beneficial. I think one thing that I heard in what Krista said is that she also felt let down because her partner didn't have a conversation with her about this. Her partner just announced,
为什么你做出这个改变会让她觉得具有威胁性或心烦意乱，并真正进行那种沟通，那种双向沟通，我认为总是受益匪浅。我认为我从克里斯塔的话中听到的一件事是，她也感到很失望，因为她的伴侣没有跟她谈论过这件事。她的伴侣只是宣布，
this is something I'm going to be doing. And in some ways, what I hear Krista saying is, you know, bring me along. If you're making this change in your life, don't just make it unilaterally. me along as you make the change. Yeah, exactly, because again, Christ is not feeling really seen if the other person is making this unilateral change. And, you know, and they may not agree on it. They may not agree on it. But at least they would have this conversation where both feel
这是我要做的事情。在某种程度上，我听到克里斯塔说的是，带上我吧。如果你在生活中做出这个改变，不要只是单方面地做。在我做出改变的时候带上我。是的，完全如此，因为再次强调，如果另一个人正在做出这种单方面的改变，克里斯塔就不会真正觉得自己被看见。而且，你知道，他们可能无法就此达成一致。他们可能无法达成一致。但至少他们可以进行这样的对话，双方都感到
understood about why they're making the decision that they're making. When we come back, could feeling unloved ever be a good thing? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Sonia Lopomirski is a scientific. psychologist at the University of California Riverside. With Harry Rees, she's the author of How to Feel Loved, the five mindsets that get you more of what matters most. Today, Sonia is answering listener questions about the psychological experience of feeling loved and what to do when we feel unloved by the people in our lives. Sonia, we received an email from a listener who asked to remain anonymous. She writes that a few years ago she was feeling burned out, so she was lucky to book a trip to
被理解，明白他们为什么要做出这样的决定。当我们回来时，感觉不被爱会是一件好事吗？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基是加州大学河滨分校的心理学科学家。她与哈里·里斯合著了《如何感受爱：让你获得更多最重要事物的五种心态》。今天，索尼娅正在回答听众关于被爱的心理体验以及当我们感觉生命中的人没有给予我们爱时该怎么做的提问。索尼娅，我们收到了一位要求保持匿名的听众发来的电子邮件。她写道，几年前她感到筋疲力尽，所以很幸运地预订了一次去
Paris for her birthday with her husband and two teenage children. The morning of her birthday started perfectly with breakfast in bed that she had ordered for herself and dapple sunlight pouring in through the windows, but then it became clear that her family hadn't done much planning for the day. She writes, what has stayed with me and still stings is my family's utter lack of effort to do something special for me. Yes, kids are teenagers and my husband was crazy busy with work. However, I would have been happy with a birthday card. A simple wish with a couple of sentences of appreciation could have been scrawled on hotel stationery or a scrap of paper. A candle stuck into a macaron would have been great. I know my family loves me. They've shown it in many ways before and since. They try to
巴黎的旅行，和她的丈夫以及两个十几岁的孩子一起庆祝生日。她生日的那天早晨以在床上吃早餐完美开始，早餐是她为自己点的，斑驳的阳光从窗户洒进来，但随后很明显，她的家人并没有为这一天做太多计划。她写道，一直留在我心头并且仍然隐隐作痛的是，我的家人完全没有努力为我做一些特别的事情。是的，孩子们是青少年，我丈夫的工作忙得疯了。然而，有一张生日卡片我也会很高兴。一句简单的祝福加上几句感激的话，随便写在酒店的信纸或一张纸条上就行。把蜡烛插在马卡龙上也会很棒。我知道我的家人爱我。他们以前和现在都在很多方面表现出来了。他们试图
make up for that day, but something about that sad birthday has lingered. So, Sonia, this listener clearly had expectations of how she wanted to be appreciated on her birthday. Talk for a moment about how she could have communicated these expectations to her family? I think this is a very common experience. When I heard from this listener, I was thinking, I wonder if she's the one who always plants things and does birthdays. And so her family is kind of used to her doing this. And I've actually seen this among friends where the person who's like so responsible
弥补那一天，但那个悲伤的生日带来的某种感觉挥之不去。所以，索尼娅，这位听众显然对她希望在生日那天如何被感激有所期望。请谈谈她本可以如何与家人沟通这些期望？我认为这是一个非常普遍的经历。当我听到这位听众的讲述时，我想，我在想她是不是那个总是计划事情和操办生日的人。所以她的家人有点习惯了她这样做。我实际上在朋友中也见过这种情况，那个非常负责任的人
who sort of takes it upon themselves. And then when it's their turn, no one does anything for them. So, you know, just like to see people with compassion. and trying to understand where they're coming from. It does not excuse or condone or justify that behavior, the fact that they did not do anything for her birthday. But I think it would lighten, kind of lighten the experience and make it a little bit easier to handle.
他们把责任揽在自己身上。然后当轮到他们时，没有人为他们做任何事。所以，你知道，试着以同情心看待人们。并试图理解他们的立场。这并没有原谅、宽恕或证明那种行为是合理的，即他们没有为她的生日做任何事。但我认为这会减轻，某种程度上减轻这种经历，让它更容易处理。
It's like, oh, they just, you know, they didn't realize it. You know, they were busy. They, you know, they thought that she didn't need it. You know, they thought she knows we love her. You know, she doesn't need a card. And again, getting back to communication, This is where maybe nonviolent communication where she says, you know, I was hurt
这就像是，哦，他们只是，你知道，他们没有意识到。你知道，他们很忙。他们，你知道，他们认为她不需要。你知道，他们认为她知道我们爱她。你知道，她不需要卡片。再次强调沟通，这就是也许非暴力沟通可以发挥作用的地方，她说，你知道，我很受伤
that you guys didn't do anything, you know, even the smallest thing, you know. I would really, I would feel so much more loved if you did this or this for me. Communication can really help. Now, of course, it's possible that this anonymous listener did communicate her expectations
你们什么都没做，你知道的，甚至是最小的事，你知道的。如果你们能为我做这个或那个，我真的，我会感觉被爱得多。沟通真的很有帮助。现在，当然，这位匿名听众有可能确实传达了她的期望
and those expectations were still not met. We don't know all the details. But it's also the case, I think, Sonia, that there's something a bit exhausting about feeling like you have to give someone a step-by-step manual for how to make yourself feel loved. I think many of us not only want to feel loved,
而这些期望仍然没有得到满足。我们并不知道所有细节。但这也是事实，我认为，索尼娅，感觉你必须给别人一本关于如何让自己感到被爱的分步手册，这本身就有点累人。我认为我们中的许多人不仅想感到被受爱，
not only want to feel loved in the way that we want to be loved, but we want the people in our lives to intuit our needs and then to deliver on them. Exactly. Well, again, there we go again, that we sort of assume that people can read our minds, right, and intuit our needs.
不仅希望以我们想要的方式被爱，而且希望我们生活中的人能够直觉到我们的需求并满足它们。没错。好吧，又来了，我们又一次认为人们能读懂我们的心，对吧，并且能直觉到我们的需求。
But I agree, and sometimes it's maybe just like a mismatch. You know, hopefully we all have partners and friends and family members that we've sort of, we're better matched in that way where we don't have to give them the step-by-step manual, because I agree, because that puts the onus on us. And then we don't feel so loved when the other person is just following our instructions. But I'm also hoping that there's other ways that say in this example of the anonymous listener that like the teenage kids and the husband probably do other things that make her feel loved. And maybe she's not even noticing those things
但我同意，有时这可能只是某种不匹配。希望我们都有这样的伴侣、朋友和家庭成员，我们在某种程度上更匹配，这样我们就不用给他们分步手册了，因为我同意，因为这把责任推给了我们。然后当另一个人只是在按照我们的指令行事时，我们就不会觉得那么被爱了。但我同时也希望还有其他方式，比如在这个匿名听众的例子中，十几岁的孩子和丈夫可能会做其他事情让她觉得被爱。也许她甚至都没有注意到那些事情
because those are not what she's looking for. And so hopefully we all can kind of tune in to all the different ways that people might make us feel love that we're not maybe even aware of. Now, I'm sure that many listeners who are, you know, hearing this conversation are thinking of times in their life
因为那些不是她在寻找的东西。所以希望我们所有人都能调整好自己，去关注人们可能让我们感到被爱但我们甚至可能都没有意识到的各种不同方式。现在，我确信听到这段对话的许多听众都会想起他们生命中的时刻
when they themselves did not feel loved or someone in their life didn't rise to the occasion. But I'm struck that even as we're thinking about these questions, we're not thinking about, in some ways, the table's being turned. You know, how often is it that we are not showing other people the love that they need in the way that they want to feel loved? I think this is actually a big issue that sometimes, like, we feel like we're trying, we're doing everything we can, and no matter what we do, the other person is not feeling loved.
当时他们自己并没有感到被爱，或者生命中的某个人没有达到预期。但我感到震惊的是，即使我们在思考这些问题时，在某种程度上我们也没有考虑到风水轮流转。你知道，我们有多少次没有向其他人展示他们所需的爱以及他们希望被爱的方式呢？我认为这实际上是一个大问题，有时，我们觉得我们在努力，我们在尽我们所能做一切，但无论我们做什么，对方就是感觉不到被爱。
And so a book really speaks to both directions, right? When we don't feel loved and we really are failing and making the other person feel loved. We heard from several listeners who wonder if feeling unloved can ever have a silver lining. A listener Michelle emailed to say that she had an unhappy childhood, but has learned from the experience as an adult. She writes, now I try to embody the love I want for myself. I give out all the time to children, to other people I randomly meet. I share myself with them. I listen to them and appreciate them.
所以这本书实际上从两个方向都进行了探讨，对吧？当我们感觉不到爱时，以及我们确实在让对方感受到爱这方面做得不够时。我们听到几位听众询问，感觉不被爱是否也会有积极的一面。听众米歇尔发邮件说，她有一个不幸的童年，但作为成年人，从这段经历中吸取了教训。她写道，现在我努力活出我为自己渴望的爱。我一直向孩子们、向我偶然遇到的其他人奉献爱。我与他们分享自己。我倾听他们并赞赏他们。
I give love. I embody the love I craved previously. And that feels important and meaningful. I also want to play you a voice message from listener Julia. Within my immediate family, I guess I felt invisible. I felt invisible. I didn't feel like I was really part of the grand scheme of things. And it led me to move to a whole other part of the country
我给予爱。我活出了我以前渴望的爱。这感觉很重要也很有意义。我还想播放一条来自听众朱莉的语音留言。在我的直系亲属中，我想我感觉自己是隐形的。我感觉自己是隐形的。我觉得自己并不是宏大计划真正的一部分。这导致我搬到了国家的另一个地方
and kind of be reborn in a sense. and meet a lot of people that kind of saw me for me. And, you know, you can't go home again. And I'm not the same me after all of that. But yeah, I have to say maybe it was a good thing. Maybe it's a good thing to not feel loved all the time. And it certainly helped me break out. So, Sonia, can feeling unloved foster a sense of resilience?
在某种程度上获得重生。并遇到了很多真正能看到真实自我的许多人。而且，你知道的，你再也回不去了。经历了这一切之后，我不再是以前那个我了。但是是的，我不得不说也许这是一件好事。有时感觉不被爱也许是一件好事。这确实帮助我突破了自我。所以，索尼娅，感觉不被爱能培养一种韧性吗？
It reminds me of the research that shows that a little adversity is good for us, that people who are, yeah, the most strong and resilient and successful actually have had a little bit of adversity. My kids have actually complained to me that we're not giving them enough adversity. But it's so interesting what both Julia and Michelle were talking about, like they didn't have love in childhood, and now they actually are somehow better off. they're somehow able to sort of take those lessons. And it makes me think about how not feeling loved is actually an evolutionarily adaptive, hardwired signal to us.
这让我想起了那些表明一点逆境对我们有益的研究，那些最坚强、最有韧性、最成功的人实际上都经历过一点逆境。我的孩子们甚至向我抱怨我们给他们的逆境不够多。但朱莉和米歇尔谈论的事情真的很有趣，就像她们童年时没有得到爱，而现在她们实际上在某种程度上过得更好了。她们不知何故能够吸取那些教训。这让我想知道，感觉不被爱实际上是一种进化的、适应性的、内置在基因里的信号。
When we don't feel loved, it's a signal to us that we need to do something about it. Maybe we need to connect, reengage, reconnect. You know, when you think about our ancestral past, right, if we didn't feel loved, that could actually literally be a danger to our lives, right? We may not find a mate. We may not be able to survive. And so in today's world, not feeling loved, almost feels like we're going to die, right? So because it's a signal to us, it's sort of a prompt or an encouragement to re-engage and to reconnect,
当我们感觉不到爱时，这是一个信号，告诉我们需要为此做点什么。也许我们需要建立联系、重新投入、重新建立联系。你知道，当你想到我们的祖先过去时，对吧，如果我们感觉不到爱，那实际上可能会对我们的生命构成真正的威胁，对吧？我们可能找不到伴侣。我们可能无法生存。所以在今天的世界里，感觉不到爱，几乎感觉就像我们要死了一样，对吧？所以因为它是给我们的一个信号，它是一种重新投入和重新连接的提示或鼓励，
it could actually have positive and beneficial consequences. Now, we very often feel unloved when we are feeling vulnerable. Listener, Tommy found that after a divorce, some friends didn't show up for him the way that he'd hoped. friends who I had known for decades sort of brushed off the news and instead of responding or choosing to respond with frustration or anger at their perceived inability to show up for me, I had to replace that with their showing up for me how they can. Then there were others that asked me what I needed and did I need a place to live? Did I need money? Did I need anything? What could they show up for?
它实际上可以产生积极和有益的结果。现在，当我们感到脆弱时，我们经常会觉得不被爱。听众汤米发现，在离婚后，一些朋友并没有像他希望的那样支持他。我认识了几十年的朋友却对这个消息不屑一顾，我没有选择用挫折或愤怒来回应他们未能支持我的感知，而是不得不将其替换为他们以他们能做到的方式支持我。然后还有其他人问我需要什么，我需要一个住处吗？我需要钱吗？我需要什么吗？他们能在什么方面提供支持？
and the expectation that everybody will show up every time in the same way, I think puts an outsized expectation on where individuals are and what they can do in that moment. And I chose to approach those people who maybe didn't show up in the way that I thought they could, but I had that choice to decide if I still love them as my friend. and I was willing to accept their flaws in my own perception of how I felt they should show up. So, Sonia, Tommy's prescription is to show more empathy for other people, even when we don't feel like it. And it strikes me that one of the benefits of doing this is that it can reduce our own feelings of resentment. What do you think?
而期望每个人每一次都以同样的方式出现，我认为对个人所处的位置以及他们在那个时刻能做的事情提出了过高的期望。我选择接触那些可能没有以我认为他们能做到的方式出现的人，但我有权决定我是否仍然爱他们作为我的朋友。并且我愿意接受他们的缺点，以及我对他们应该如何出现的个人看法的局限。所以，索尼娅，汤米的方法是对其他人表现出更多的同情，即使在我们不想这样做的时候。我突然想到，这样做的好处之一是可以减少我们自己内心的怨恨。你觉得呢？
I so agree with Tommy. I think it's such a healthy, evolved, mature response. It reminds me of something a friend who's a coach taught me, which is that some people are just, we're all doing the best we can, and some people are just at capacity. And if they could show up for us more, they would, but they can't. And she kept saying that to me,
我太赞同汤米了。我认为这是一种非常健康、进化、成熟的反应。这让我想起了一位担任教练的朋友教给我的一件事，那就是有些人只是——我们都在尽力而凡事量力而行，有些人确实已经达到了他们的极限。如果他们能更多地支持我们，他们会的，但他们不能。她一直对我说，
if they could, they would, but they can't. And this is exactly what's happening with Tommy's friends. And maybe there's other times that they're showing up for him. And so that kind of compassion that he has for them, I think it's really beautiful. It also reminds me of when my husband's father died, he had one of his friends never said anything. And he was so upset.
如果他们能，他们就会，但他们不能。这正是汤米的朋友们身上发生的事情。也许他们在其他时候支持过他。因此，他对他们怀有的那种同情，我认为真的很美妙。这也让我想起了我丈夫的父亲去世时，他的一位朋友什么也没说。他非常沮丧。
He was so upset. And I think they never even apologized for not to say anything. I really, now that I look back on it, I think this person just didn't know what to say. It just was so hard for them. They just couldn't. They just couldn't. They're not a bad person. He forgave them.
他非常沮丧。而且我想他们甚至没有为没有说什么而道歉。我现在回想起来，我认为这个人只是不知道该说些什么。这对他来说太难了。他们就是做不到。他们就是做不到。他们不是坏人。他原谅了他们。
But it's sort of that example that like for there's lots of reasons why someone just cannot show up for us in that moment and to forgive them, really to forgive them and to move on. is really healthy. I mean, I remember when I was in high school and one of my classmates died, I remember going over to his family home with some of my other classmates. And I really didn't have anything to say. I didn't have a word to say. Now, of course, I was a teenager at the time. And so perhaps it's understandable.
但这就像是一个例子，有很多原因导致某人在那个时刻无法支持我们，而原谅他们，真正地原谅他们并继续前进，是非常健康的。我的意思是，我记得我上高中时，我的一个同班同学去世了，我记得我和其他一些同班同学一起去了他家。我真的没什么可说的。我连一句话也说不出来。当然，那时我还是个青少年。所以也许这是可以理解的。
But in some ways, that's true for all of us, right? At different stages of our lives, you know, we can experience other people going through difficult times and really just simply not know how to respond. and then we want to say something, but we don't know what to say. Exactly. Exactly. We're sort of at capacity or whatever you, you know, we're doing the best we can, and we just can't.
但在某些方面，这对我们所有人来说都是真的，对吧？在我们人生的不同阶段，你知道，我们可以经历其他人经历艰难时期，而真的只是简单地不知道该如何回应。然后我们想说点什么，但又不知道该说什么。
At that moment, we just can't. But then to the other person, sometimes it's very hard to accept. And so, but I feel like as we all get older, we're sort of more accepting because we've seen, yeah, Shankar, like we've both had these experiences and we've been on the other side, we've been on both sides of it, right? And I think that helps us sort of move on and forgive. What do you do, Sonia, when you don't feel loved? Yeah, it's so hard.
精确地。精确地。我们有点达到极限了或者无论你怎么说，你知道，我们都在尽力而为，但我们就是做不到。在那一刻，我们就是做不到。但对另一个人来说，有时这很难接受。所以，但我觉得随着我们年龄的增长，我们会更加包容，因为我们见过，是的，香卡，就像我们俩都有过这些经历，而且我们都曾在另一边，我们都经历过双方，对吧？我认为这有助于我们继续前进和原谅。当你感觉不到爱时，索尼娅，你会怎么做？是的，这太难了。
I do try to communicate to the person. There was one actually experience I think I talked about on the previous show where someone sort of was not texting me and was not communicating with me. And I did communicate that, that I needed to have that communication to feel more loved. But then the other thing I do is really comes from advice of the book is that if you don't feel love, sometimes the response is to try to make the other person feel more loved, to kind of go first, which seems a little bit unfair, right, to show curiosity in them, to show warmth towards them, to truly listen to them.
我确实试着与那个人沟通。实际上我有一段经历，我想我在上期节目中谈到过，当时某人没有给我发短信，也没有跟我沟通。我确实表达了这一点，我需要这种沟通来感受到更多的爱。但随后我做的另一件事其实来自于这本书的建议，那就是如果你感觉不到爱，有时你的反应是试着让另一个人感觉更被爱，去主动出击，这看起来似乎有点不公平，对吧，对他们表现出好奇心，对他们表现出温暖，真正地倾听他们。
And if that doesn't work, then that's when you might give up and walk away. Sonia Lubomirski is a psychologist at the University of California, Riverside. With Harry Reese, she's the author of How to Feel Loved. the five mindsets that get you more of what matters most. Sonia Lubomirsky, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. It's always a pleasure to talk to you, Shankar. We also heard today from Edward LeMay. He's a psychologist at the University of Maryland. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
如果这不管用，那么你可能才会放弃并走开。索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基是加州大学河滨分校的心理学家。她与哈里·里斯合著了《如何感受爱：让你获得更多最重要事物的五种心态》。索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。和您交谈总是很高兴，香卡。我们今天还听到了爱德华·勒迈的发言。他是马里兰大学的心理学家。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy listening to the show, you'll enjoy watching it as well. Subscribe to our new YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash at Hidden Brain so you don't miss any of our videos. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢收听这个节目，你也会喜欢观看它。订阅我们在 YouTube 上的新频道 YouTube.com 斜杠 at Hidden Brain，这样你就不会错过我们的任何视频。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。回头见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。